a yale
lecturer spoke about
her desire to brutally murder a bunch of
white people because
we're at this and uh we got a bunch of
cool people hanging out but i must i
must point out to my to everybody
listening
last night uh we had a technician come
out turns out
our internet was struck by lightning
dead serious oh and so it fried some of
the ground wiring we're in the middle of
nowhere so we have long
ground wires that run from our property
out into where the street is and then
connecting up and uh at some point it
got struck by lightning and it fried the
cable going up our property so they laid
a cable like
on top of the ground quite literally a
squirrel could walk up to it and nibble
and we get
cut off but uh hey maybe we'll have
internet for this show
otherwise uh welcome to rural living but
uh we're hanging out with some
some great people we have the one and
only g prime85 george
alex opolis that's right i only pulled
that microphone brother
what's going on everybody thank you for
inviting me yes absolutely you have a a
picture behind you of joe biden eating
okay boomer girl
oh my goodness whoever drew that must be
a conspiracy theorist
some something is wrong with whoever
drew that what kind of freak
you know i bet that person only has one
joke
yeah that's that's you know like like
talentless waste of talent
say something obnoxious then empty panel
empty panel and then
shocked what kind of jerk
i did you do you read a lot of junji ido
i love gingee yeah that's kind of weird
he's uh
you know he's he was trying to be a
dentist i think at one point wow
and he decided to draw horror manga so
whatever he saw
in the dental school inspired him
well now you uh joe biden is a monster
looking out of the walls and eating okay
boomer girl which is interesting because
okay boomer girl's back in the news
because she bought a two million i don't
know if she bought it but she has a two
million dollar apartment
yes and she's getting slammed because
for some reason these
young socialists are always very proud
to be successful capitalists
but you know whatever well really that's
the power of uh you know
looking good and that's why i'm also
buying a million dollar house
exactly i i too uh on my patreon you
know people are paying me to take off my
shirt
because everyone wants to see that the
only only fans live on this show
i'm going to at least not okay i wonder
if there was like a
internet i wonder if there was a point
where you know like bernie sanders is
looking at his speech
and it says like millionaires and the
billionaires and then his a he's like
his assistant or eight or whatever goes
uh mr sanders you are now a millionaire
it was okay and he just
scratches out millionaire the
billionaires just the billionaires
don't worry millionaires are fine person
perspective
i assume are good people there's nothing
not all the bills very fine people
yeah so uh well you've probably noticed
that sheamus is here as well i'm also
here we have two cartoonists on tonight
this is unbelievable why would you do
this it may cause a singularity
yeah exactly some problems i don't know
what's going to happen by the end we
need a crossover where it's like a
freedom tunes thing where it's like it's
very
it's very hokey kind of like violence
you know what i mean what
you know i mean like like they punch
we need to throw in some like you know g
prime junji ito style vibes of like
joe biden eating a child or something oh
my gosh you know someday maybe 10 years
from now
i want to have drawn at least one other
thing that people remember me by
that'd be very nice well it's it's just
that we have two of your comics
and behind sheamus is joe biden eating a
child yes and behind
you george is joe biden eating okay
boomer girl yeah
that's true what do you really believe
what kind of sick mind
really that's what this is an
intervention isn't it yes
yeah i'm here today thanks for coming
these cartoons really are an act of
violence
they really are that's true i got to
know george uh tuesday i was talking
about
i was just desperate to see a fouchy
image oh then
up on twitter the next day yeah had you
been working on that did you whip it up
that night
no no uh every morning this is my
process it's
amazing and everyone cares so i wake up
real early i take a shower
i breakfast you know i'm looking through
my twitter and i see what's in the news
and i s
you know tw fauci was trending whatever
so it's
for a long time i've i had this one
image of him
where was he there was a
there was a biden like in holding a
needle or something and he was in the
background looking kind of creepy
oh yeah and then i said you know let's
feature him as
the as you know let's caricature him in
that six flags kind of way and then i
start like exaggerating just doodling
for fun
so by eight o'clock in the morning i
finished my breakfast i'm like oh this
is an actual thing that i have to finish
drawing now
yes and it's this horrifying again by
accident i wasn't intending these are my
warm-ups most of the time
and then it finished i uploaded whatever
new wilker
yeah ian was furious he was screaming he
was like i want a picture of vouching
he's like punching holes
and george does as ian commands that's
how and that's just how it works in the
artistic community
yeah ian called george and get me that
photograph
i want pictures of dr fauci
then he got it that checks out yeah what
i want to serve
yeah we got lydia's pushing buttons i am
i'm pushing buttons in the corner and
it's going to be a great show i'm loving
all the artistic
yeah we have artists here and to talk
about something cartoonishly
ridiculous which is a woman giving a
lecture at yale a psychiatrist of all
people
yes yes before we get into the news
though you guys you got to go to
timcast.com of course
and become a member to get access to
exclusive members only segment last
night we did a full bonus episode
where me and sheamus were screaming at
each other he punched me in the face
right in the face nunchucks under the
table so i sprung back up it was a
brutal and intense debate
caught his wrist yeah but then ian had a
whip
it was no actually ian ian channeled
plasma and fired a plasma ball at me
and i just there's a window behind me
you can't take it's covered up and i
just flew 40 feet in the air
how did you how did you forget how did
you confuse that for having a whip right
well because he had both
struck by lightning they said yeah i was
a little out of it after i got hit in
the forehead with the nunchucks you know
but my hair is able to come up cover up
the scar what really happened and it
looks like the internet might be working
right now is our wow literally got
struck by lightning
so like we had a guy come out and he was
like this is a problem and i was like
what happened he's like
the cable underground is fried and i was
i was like oh
he's like i think it got struck by
lightning whoa and i was like oh whoa
i wonder if it was poorly insulated do
you have any any thoughts about that i
don't know maybe
you just can't stop it the lightning i
don't know you can't stop the lightning
stop the lightning it seems likely how
about we talk about this crazy lady in
the current state
i think that's a little unfair i
wouldn't call her crazy
oh okay here's here's the story so we
pulled this up from the federal list
here's what i love the federalist
is called fake news by news guard but
this story is like 100 legit
over at barry weiss's sub stack katie
herzog wrote about this interviewed this
person
and the federalist writes it up they get
called fake news but it's like it's 100
verifiable
lecturer at official yale event
fantasizes about brutally murdering
white people
claims all white people are rotten i
don't know if i can read what she said
on youtube
i don't think you but well let me just
put it this way
it's not something somebody should be
able to get away with saying on a
college campus considering the
environment we're in politically and
also the fact that there have been mass
shootings in educational settings repeat
botch it and get us demonetized that
white people are deranged
uh and her talk was on the psychopathic
problem of the white mind so i don't
know what they expect actually then yeah
yeah
the psychopathic problem of the white
mind i don't know what they thought she
was gonna talk about what she was gonna
say but yes it did involve using a
weapon
using a weapon against the head putting
placing it to the head of a person
and um i'm not sure how much yeah i'm
not getting in trouble here tim
in an official lecture called the
psychopathic problem of the white mind
given by
aruna kilanon kilani yeah wow
at the yale school of medicine's
department of child study center
kelinani graphically described her
fantasy about killing and burying white
people i'm not going to read them
normal college stuff yeah you know
sounds like slam poetry
yeah exactly she's just delivering a
little slam poem dude talk about
murdering the english language
oh my goodness fair enough well played
so here's
so obviously this lady's psychotic and
this is really
this is we're getting into seriously
dangerous territory yeah what's
fascinating is that there are a lot of
people i think like scott adams
was talking about how all of the white
privilege stuff was bubbling into i
mean maybe it wasn't scott adams but
correct me if i'm wrong talk about how
like this rhetoric will lead to genocide
yeah all these cartoonists making great
points yeah that was scott right yeah
scott and it's funny because like um
i wouldn't say he's 100 right just yet
i'm not saying he's wrong i'm saying
straight up being like this is what i
want to fantasize about this is what i
do and this is what's insane so she was
previously a professor she taught at
cornell columbia and new york university
which is fantastic to have a professor
going out there saying things like they
want to
kill people of a specific race but also
she's a psychiatrist which to me seems
strange i don't know that this is a
person who i would want to go to for
psychological help
she likes i can't even make some of
these jokes i know it's just
it's like it's dude it's so over the top
right there she said white people sound
demented and it's just crazy to me that
she was able to get through this speech
you can't all right
first of all the thought of even going
on a college campus
and talking about intentionally harming
people being violent against them
with a deadly weapon i would imagine is
enough to get you thrown off even if
it's not
racially based you're not but you know
talking about a specific group of people
it seems to me it's like saying bomb on
an airplane or something i i can't
believe right there's
there's a difference between telling
people to do something and to say you're
fantasizing about doing it
but i mean there's now also kind of not
really a difference
and i know that this is like the cliche
thing that every conservative says
imagine if the situations were reversed
but seriously
i just imagine any professor going out
there and picking out a racial minority
and saying that they wanted to do
this to them it would be on the front
end yeah also it would be on the front
page of everything and it would be used
as an excuse to censor every other
conservative so so you're gonna love
this this is this is the caliber of
people now
lecturing at these universities so in
the interview katie says
uh could you give me an example of what
of how this is picked up in all aspects
of culture how do you see the after
effects of colonialism manifesting
itself in the white mind today
this woman this crazy lady says it's
going to be hard for me to give you one
sentence sound bite on this but i would
say a high level of guilt
i've never seen anything like this
before other than in white
people not eating bread an incredible
level of shame
feeling really exposed all the time a
lot of perfectionist tendencies
and so some somehow like it's it seems
like katie's trying to have like an
honest conversation with this lady's
like
bread they don't eat bread and then she
goes on to say
uh let me let me find like white so it
does seem like you generalize a lot this
is katie about white people
but also people of color why do you do
that and this woman says why do you feel
uh why what do you feel as a
generalization katie asks
like white people having a high level of
guilt or not
eating bread that's true for some that's
true for some people for sure but i eat
bread
and then she says you don't think you're
generalizing the lady goes on and and
somehow
it it comes back to this sure this is
katie
there are a lot of white people who
don't eat bread although i am not one of
them
i exclusively eat bread i don't think
katie exclusively
however she goes on also i'm skeptical
of some claims of gluten intolerance but
my assumption has always been
that they're just buying into
pseudoscientific bs and following health
needs
you think it's white guilt the lady goes
on an emotional level absolutely
like if i raise an eyebrow at a white
person around bread
the first response is like it's real
what does that mean
they mean it's not psychological right
it's a medical issue not a mental one
says katie
the lady goes i don't deny that people
may get symptoms
but how is it that all the violence has
occurred are not eating bread
it's like the weirdest effing thing
katie says but what does bread have to
do with violence what's the connection
there
i think the bread is about guilt and
needing to keep them in a state of
deprivation
and stay guilty okay
that's the famous bread section of this
lady's interview that's brilliant
now could you imagine paying that person
to go to a college and teach your
children
you may notice white people not eating
bread why because they're racist guess
what i want to do to them this is what
we have to do to wipe them for not
eating bread ladies and gentlemen this
is the only solution you heard about
that socialist want breadlines guess
what something much worse
we don't want anyone having any bread
dude yell dude there's at least the
footage
obviously for good reason and she claims
it's because they're trying to suppress
her
it's like first did you imagine like
she's in a starbucks and the lady's like
the message needs to be censored i know
like the well the message needs to be
too real part of me wonders if like yale
is just kind of trying to help her by
downplaying this because they know the
more it gets out there the worse this
person's life is going to be i'm not
sure what y'all's motivations are maybe
they're helping her with their silence
as dave chappelle would say
or did say this is the kind of thing
where it's like this instance like
like this lady will be in a subway or
something and someone will be like
um do you have anything without bread
and then she looks and goes like
you remember uh body snatchers when
donald trump's like
she's not eating bread it proves it i
thought i thought ebermex kennedy's
thing was crazy when he was like
denying racism as proof of racism i was
like well that's nuts now we've got i'm
sorry this is crazier
if you don't eat bread you're racist i
just realized
i'm black wait a second okay so i coming
over here driving right
i had in my car cold cuts pastrami
turkey listen in a in a ziploc bag and
i'm reaching
into the ziploc bag with my bare hands
and eating the cold cuts
no bread oh racist i'm black
but that's actually cool because you're
racist yeah she said if you don't know
i've only been black for a little while
no no she says
you're racist yes wait she's not saying
white people believe i'm actually saying
white people don't so it's racist
to not eat bread so am i correct here
i'm i'm trying to figure out the rules
right now i don't want this lady to come
to my house remember
remember when milk was racist yes it was
quite
weird you only get lactate well it's
because asian people don't drink milk i
guess
black people don't either really yeah is
that a thing yeah it is
actually it is yeah in other countries
people tend to lose their tolerance for
milk as they mature
i've heard people for whatever reason
they're definitely genetic differences
you know like um
sickle cell anemia seems to have strike
the african-american community harder
than other
you know genetic races or whatever
that's not that's not true
that's true yeah sickle cell anemia was
like notably found in
in like african culture no rice is a
social construct ian
oh well that's true yeah i i have
nowhere to go so not so now just
wait what do you do the door's right
there maybe you still have somewhere
maybe certain people are more sensitive
to gluten intolerance i don't know is
there something to that i've never heard
that before
is there anything else it's really an
ice
yeah that's a good alternative to ice
cream
you know you know they do they make
that's racist how do we pay for our
two million dollar apartment
oh my gosh i'm gonna eat only bread i
can't afford anything else is okay
boomer girl right
i have no idea because i think like they
just they they just now will say they
are
they aren't even if they they are she's
latinx though latinx
latinx latinos like kleenex yeah yeah
like kleenex i hear how it's pronounced
latinx or is it latinx yeah i don't know
like kleenex latinx yeah okay
like latino latina latinx that's great
and how much how many latino people
actually
latinas i think it is yeah exactly
there we go yes college women it's a
white college woman mostly too or
probably
yeah it is definitely everything has to
be cleansed including language
they love it when you uh cleanse their
language yeah when you yes
exactly yes people from other cultures
love when white people come around and
tell them that their culture is actually
insensitive
i have my latinx friends that i have to
go over to their house and just like hey
i heard you talking
yeah and your fake language that's not
real anymore hold on hold on like where
where is
where's the person just kind of roll
with this to like go to one of these
meetings or hang out with some woke
people
and just absolutely play into it oh that
was what art school was for me
so when they when they say like latinx
you go oh oh t-r-o-b-f-n-two plus q
absolutely i'm i'm i'm trying to
remember the best i'm getting wrong
but it was like 15 or 16 letters yes
and so when i'm reading it i'm like the
activists wrote this message saying we
stand in solidarity with the lgbtq iap2
plus trob ny x3 community
and i'm like i literally have no idea
what that means i'm not trying to be
disrespectful i'm literally like i
i don't know the message you're trying
to convey to me about chick-fil-a
there's too many letters there to learn
the kind of code and then there's
another one
there's another code that's like
trans-indigenous
yeah trans-indigenous people of color
and like other
it's like it's like tapocany or
something like that like at some point
you lose the entire purpose of having a
group and
the point of an acronym is you're
supposed to keep it short right it's
supposed to be something that like
everyone can just say
you need to remember people easy to
remember and also it's supposed to refer
to like a limited group of people so you
start tacking on all these letters and
it defeats the entire purpose
like the fired act that one was fouchy
incompetence requires early dismissal
yeah that's brilliant
excellent fire the guy yeah yeah but
that's why i'm i'm confused because i
wonder why it is people don't speak up
and just say outright like this is
like not communicable you know what i
mean like i don't know
what it is you're convinced oh they're
scared all of them are scared that's the
thing too i wonder how many of them
actually believe this because i met a
number of people again
i was sort of joking earlier about art
school but i met a number of people who
behind closed doors
wouldn't say all this far left stuff in
fact they would agree with me that
um the left has gone off the deep end a
lot of the other students were
really uh too far to the left and made
them feel uncomfortable to voice their
own opinions but
and then i guess i ended up wondering is
that really true or do you just kind of
say whatever the group is saying and so
now that you're around me you're saying
something you think i might agree with
it's hard to know but i
imagine there's a large number of these
people who do think it's way over the
top who do think it's a little silly
maybe they believe in the cause but they
think all these extra letters are
ridiculous but they're just not going to
say it because they're terrified well
you know you know what will happen if
these people do
it's not even necessarily about getting
cancelled it's about just a a net
detriment to their lives
yeah exactly you don't want to get put
down as the racist you don't want to
have to be lectured at and educated by
your friends
it's not even that it's a homophobia i
won't i i won't get a speaking position
or i'll get a worse grade or uh you know
people will
start saying mean things about me on
facebook it's just like i don't want to
deal with the stress
this woman lecturing at yale will point
a weapon at me do you think
she uh graded white students fairly
yeah no yeah no definitely not
she's like that's the early seasons of
simpsons were the best
oh yeah no i'm a huge fan i've i've
watched basically every episode until
like maybe season 25 or something it's
horrible now i'm sure you know that no
we had like adult swim back in the
sarcastic
it's it's actually uh no not mike judge
all right so beavis and butthead was
mike judge yeah yeah it's a spin-off
right because she's writers
right but just it's very smart comedy i
like the
nowadays like i don't actually love the
seth macfarlane stuff so much
it's more like gag-ish yeah 100 as
opposed to
i don't know cultural commentary well
that's the thing like
gags are great to take you through
something really short but when it's
like 22 minutes long and i'm supposed to
be roped into a story i kind of stopped
caring about it when
my attention is brought in every
different direction for some short cheap
joke
so i hear you especially with the
mcfarland stuff i think they have a
thing where every 10 seconds or
something we have to
do a joke even if it's a flashback well
that reminds me of the time i
yeah exactly it doesn't really advance
the story at all comedy or something
you guys you got to understand this this
lecture at yale you know she's fighting
very serious
mainstream oppression that's true yeah i
know you know just recently
we have this viral video this viral meme
has been going around for some time
that's true
uh skittles i don't know if you guys
know that skittles oh boy
absolutely uh it's a neo-nazi
organization racist racist company
rainbow we have uh oh we have this photo
more we're not tasting we
have this photo and it's a it's a bag of
skittles it's all white
and it says skittles white pride it's
literally
it's what the skittles the skittles are
white
gray they're literally white white and
it says and it says
on the uh not none of the skills bag but
on the label at the spa
store it's a skittles white pride it
says that yes yes yeah
they want to do something unique for
pride month so but think
think about this like okay joking aside
joking aside
skittles thought it was appropriate to
remove all of the colored
ones to replace all of the skittles with
just white ones i'm like
that is the stupidest marketing campaign
i have
ever heard of here's the thing it is
really dumb but then again
we are talking about them every single
company does this pride month stuff and
i guess skittles
is like we're going to shake it up and
what did they say this is the initiative
shake it up like this is the only
rainbow that matters or they said
something only one rainbow matters this
month
so and i'm thinking that's a promise god
made to not flood the earth again
because that's what the rainbow
is for but then it got stolen and now
it's just a cheap marketing gimmick that
every company
uses in june a lot of people can just
skittles like they made a bag of white
skittles
they removed the colored skittles i
don't know what they were thinking this
was supposed to be
they should have just been like you know
like this is the rainbow whatever
june is the perfect month for skittles
what if they taste the rainbow
come on exactly they could be like look
we were supporting pride all along since
the brand started existing we've always
been about the rainbow that's what we
were trying to tell you but wait
here's here's what's funny right so you
see how all these brands change their
twitter accounts yes
so they put like you know rainbow levels
but then in saudi arabia they don't
skittles decided to go the complete
other direction you take the rainbow out
and then make all of the skittles white
that's a really good idea that's
inclusive co-workers are like that's
really smart man
dude you were thinking you know what
you're here
you ever hear the story of how hot
cheetos flame hot chocolate no i think
it was like a gem you know the story
i was going to say hillary clinton got
to him oh my gosh
that's awesome that's awesome no no it
wasn't it was
in my bag so so it's a crazy story
apparently it was like a janitor right
and the the ceo or something put out a
company wide message saying we respect
all of our employees
you know to that that being said if
anybody has any ideas we're always
listening
and so this one dude who worked there he
would always take the dry cheetos with
no cheese on
them and they were extras he'd bring
them home and he would put chili powder
on them and shake him up
and it was a lot like uh like some kind
of mexican snack not necessarily a lotus
but something like that
and so then when pete when his family
started trying it they were like you
should you should tell them
and so then apparently like made a video
or something and sent it in and
everybody at the company was like what
are you doing don't
send us they don't the ceo isn't serious
and then when they got the message and
they saw this and they realized that
people really liked the snack they were
like let's let's try making let's make
it and it's it's like the number one or
became the number one
like chip snack that was sold in stores
so this guy got promoted became this
high level six figure dude they really
meant it's one of the coolest stories
ever yeah that is great actually this
one's got to be the opposite
like some kids like i got a really good
idea for for diversity and pride
get rid of all of the colored skittles
here's the question though i mean we're
making fun of them for it but has this
been negatively received
or are they doing like tweeted an image
that says skittles white pride
oh my god i don't think skittles is
having a good day of this
maybe you never know dude people could
buy into it they could be like this is a
great skittles that was very brave
skittles
dude i wish i was emotional i wish i was
a multi-million dollar corporation so i
could like
fight oppression with like junk mail
about blm and
i'm sure i'm sure you're right that
there are many identitarians who are
cheering this just like the left cheers
for all their little corporate logos i'm
sure
there are a certain sect of a certain
racial editorial group that's very happy
that skittles made a white pride bag
you know this is a problem i have all
their logos are white by the way i just
looked at their twitter oh did they
change it to gray did they change them
to gray as part of the backlash
oh bro this is the worst thing ever they
also their number
their top tweet right now our most
recent tweet second most recent is
hey samsung girl they get us fellow kids
you know what i mean oh yeah you guys
see this the samsung girl that
everyone's like that's gonna end really
well
oh they made them gray they changed it
they made the skittles
well i think calling them colored
skittles was uh probably the mistake in
the first place
i would say so yeah i have an
inappropriate joke can i say it no
no there's like a scale is a family
friendly no
you know what it's it's my reputation on
the line what do you call colored
skittles oh no no no
no no no no delicious
don't do this delicious yes don't do
this ian was correct
this is a problem i have with calling
people oh wait do you want to do you
want to answer that joke i think it's
too risky
let's save the punchline for the after
show
wait is there going to be i don't know
yeah oh there's no after show on fridays
you get it easy let me let me derail
this one real quick i didn't even say
the joke all right
do you really quick um this is a problem
i have with calling people black and
white
is that firstly we're not and then when
people try and
market like white candy all of a sudden
it's considered racist
which is insane because there's no way
stupidest thing
it's stupid it's stupid yeah agreed
thing i think it was i don't think it
was just that it was just white candy
but like white if people were upset
about this i think like the combination
of white and pride together might have
yeah we hear people were upset
with sex somehow sexuality yeah the
rainbow
tastes talk about tasting the rainbow
yeah there you go that's pretty good
yeah that's pretty good
every joke i have is rated arms come on
george so
uh ian ian is wearing the are you
wearing the gorilla this is the og
i am a gorilla let me stand up and get
this on so so we when we first made this
shirt many many of you may not be
familiar uh
the this shirt was misprinted where for
some reason teespring made the face of
the gorilla
uh darkened black but only the inside of
the face so it looked like it was paint
and the hands were white which makes no
sense because it's just a gorilla
and it was like what a weird thing to do
to paint the face of the gorilla black
and give him white
hands terrible strange and so created
this huge controversy
and then you know t spring fixed it
apologized but i was i was like i was
i was you know pissed off a lot of
people were messaging me saying like why
is there a blackface gorilla shirt like
what is this and i'll be like dude
clearly we don't sell that that's not
it's just meant to be a meme about the
show it's
an inside joke about alex jones and then
i started getting lefties once
once once i called it out saying like
this is not our mistake
the lefties were like having a gorilla
t-shirt was racist enough
what no joke and i was like extremely
racist i
know i know that's a ridiculously racist
thing to say
together i was like dude it's it's like
magilla gorilla isn't a race thing it's
a cartoon it's like
having a shirt this amarillo was a
reference to ishmael is no reference to
race
if you see that and think race man you
got problems you have
serious problems these people say
they're racist
like robin d'angelo she writes she wrote
a book about it she says she's racist
well there you go they're not lying
that's true she walked into a party and
saw the group of black people and said
you know what i'm scared of those that's
a true story though she said that she
literally wrote that yeah
wow and she's like a foremost expert and
lecturer on critical race theory
she wrote in her book that when she goes
to parties with black people she's
uncomfortable around them and i'm like
dude ladies weird thing to say original
sin man yeah
people people like like most people
don't feel that way that's so
weird i don't know man is it is it is
this is this something i'm missing like
i grew up in chicago so
i don't have like i don't think of the
world that way and she's from the
suburbs or something i don't
know what it i but even though you can
like i mostly grew up in the suburbs and
i don't feel that way i think it's just
a weird
putting race on a pedestal uh pedestal
type thing
where you're gonna evaluate people on
that basis for better or for worse
i mean it's the way the left has said
that we should analyze people and she's
on the left so that's how she's going to
look at everybody she's going to put
them in those categories and if she
feels uncomfortable maybe it just
becomes well i must be uncomfortable
because of that person's race because
i've internalized racism or maybe she
actually just like straight up is racist
i don't i'll tell you this i i went to
oh well yes she obviously is of course
but you get what i mean
i was in thailand during chinese new
year
in i think 2014 and i was standing in
this market
where there were like thousands of
people on the streets doing their thing
i could see i could see clean all the
way like
like everybody was shorter than me so i
was standing you know with my friends
and i could i had clear field of view
all the way down the market and it's an
interesting thing you know when these
people say that like raises a social
construct and then you go to thailand
and you're like
then i go to scandinavia and i'm in a
crowd and i can't see anything at all
because everyone's seven feet tall
no it's true though you just thought
they were because like internalized
races but
i wonder if a big component of this of
like robin deangelo's fear is that she's
never
been you know what i mean like she's
never actually interacted with these
people
and so if if these people who think race
doesn't exist
ever actually traveled another country
they might be like hey
like people here tend to be a little
shorter people here tend to be a little
taller and
hey guess what in america race is not a
you have no reason to be uncomfortable
it's like the weirdest the weirdest
thing to be uncomfortable about in my
opinion like
what about that does she not feel
comfortable with you know what i mean
reminds me of male feminists
who want to hang out around other women
like listen i'm a pig when i'm
around you the thoughts that are in my
head let me just tell you for a happy
you know what i just like i was tempted
to say you shouldn't vote when i first
walked into the room
you know how inappropriate it would be
if i said this this year yeah
i just aren't meant such pigs the guys
in the party really is the equivalent
yeah like
one of these male feminists in the
parties look at the women and he goes uh
i just think we should repeal the night
i'm sorry i'm sorry i can't help it yeah
i was on
and i thought it was wrong of me but
it's what i thought
i just wanted to end women's suffrage
haven't they suffraged enough yes they
definitely have some would say so
man that's i think you're right about uh
deangelis not being familiar
rather than be like it's because of the
race i'm uncomfortable it's if you don't
if it's unfamiliar to you yeah it might
you might be uncomfortable with
something
new whether it's the height the skin
tone
the way that the posture of the body is
i don't know i don't know what she was
saying though yeah and that's
it's weird i i think maybe she's just
like never met a black person before she
wrote these books
that i can understand if you grow up in
a cloistered environment around one
color and and size of human and then you
go to an environment where
a bunch of all humans are a different
shape and size
and color why size she grows in the
shire bro
probably yeah well she yeah she is
i don't feel uncomfortable going to
thailand like noticing that
you know people who are shorter than me
like i don't i also
it's meaningless she might have been
beat up as a kid not even as racially
just she might have been abused as a
child so she has fear uh in general
in her life unresolved fear or something
i think it's just that she's
racist but you have close communities
that have negative views
and then you have elitist racist views
so like she probably grew up in this
hoity-toity like white community with
their mom being like
oh you know talk down to people
condescend you're so much better and
it's like the whole ideology of these
people is that they are better
like no joke it is a form of white
supremacy
not in the same sense they try to convey
right so their version of white
supremacy makes little little sense
they're like prejudice plus power yes
but when you think about the core of
their ideology that they think that
white people hold special privileged
positions and have more power more
control
and they literally tell minorities they
can't succeed i'm like bro i think
you're a white supremacist you know what
i mean well i i think for some of them
what it is
it's sort of the phenomena you see with
the the kid
who didn't do that poorly on a test but
they complained about how poorly they
did like they want you to think that
they think their grade is bad
so someone will get like an a minus and
go oh i did so bad on this and then you
ask how they did and they got an a minus
so they're saying they did something bad
but it's really for the purpose of
signaling how great they are
that's kind of what i think it's not oh
i was racist but i'm aware of it
you're talking about asians right what
maybe maybe how they get a a's instead
of a pluses
and then i'm sorry it's funny to me
it's very funny to me i had a friend who
was chinese valedictorian
amazing grades perfect right cried about
getting an a minus on one of her finals
i'm like are you kidding me i would
kill to have a c on anything
that's the end of my joke but it's not a
joke that's totally true
yeah asians are smarter
i don't i think i think hold on hold on
think about this
you have you you grew up in a household
where you feel
shame for not getting a perfect score
you know
oh yeah the i mean the strictness in
reality the the strictness of these
parents
as well if you're if you're happy with
getting a c like george and i become a
cartoonist
have you ever played those like mobile
games where you got to like it's like a
puzzle game there's one where
there's one game i play sometimes it's
like you you press the start button and
water comes out but you have to like
draw
a ramp to like get the water to go into
the bucket see those ads constantly okay
now hold on hold on
so like it's it's what it's called but
like a water faucet you'll draw a
picture
you can draw lines and the water follows
the line you try to get to like ramp up
into the bucket
and you have to get three stars when i
get two stars i read to the level
i'm like you didn't beat the level
unless you get all three stars you know
oh
that's not how i work you just get one
step like i'm going through
all of them first and then i'll go back
and like and do it try and get three
stars on the ones that i didn't bro you
should've
seen me beat sonic the hedgehog earlier
i didn't care how many
rings i got i was like to the end of the
level yeah see i have to get literally
every ring in the game
otherwise i start the whole thing over
no not not that much you unplug the
arcade machine
but it's like if you don't if like i've
got one game where you have like a
little guy needs a backflip and you tap
the screen and he jumps and you tap it
again and he tucks and then you
let go and then he lands the back flip
yeah and i'm like i gotta get in the
ring perfect max score every time and if
i don't i just keep restarting until i
do it
it's frustrating like i feel like if i
don't get a perfect score i didn't beat
the level
yeah you know yeah i'm not gonna cry
about it do you think that's a
nature-nurture thing i've always
man this is interesting um i think it's
probably a little bit of both yeah but i
definitely grew up in a household where
when i like before i even started
kindergarten my mom was teaching me math
and reading yeah that's good so i
started kindergarten i knew
multiplication and division and long
division all stuff
like all the other kids were like two
plus two is four and i was like
27 times 493 like i could do the math
you know
so maybe it's my cultural thing does
your parents expect like greatness out
of you
and and punish or not punish you but
like be like it wasn't good enough if
you didn't get
the perfect score or were they just kind
of like hands off the video game they
made him replay video game levels if he
didn't beat it completely
no but there was this game we used to
play in first grade called around the
world i love that game yeah you know
what it is like
so you stand up at your desk and then
you stand behind the person with your
hands on their shoulder and then the
teacher would do a flash card
me and my brother would never lose so
the teacher would eventually ask us to
stop playing
yeah because it's like first grade and
show the card back boom i know the
answer seven
fourteen three isn't that ridiculous
what an example of how
public schools busted the smart kids
this is catholic school
even catholic schools busted the kids
that are so good can't
can't participate because they ruin it
for everyone else what are they supposed
to do i don't know i have this again
they're like tim we get it you know your
math have a nice day like you won here's
your prize now
go go play with your prize like the
other kids got to learn math too
so what is it is it it's interesting
right so uh
i'm literally asian and i'm good at math
i've had this theory for a long time
because
you said that tim i'm allowed to say it
well i grew up around a lot of asian
kids uh just
in the area that i lived in so i would
go to their houses and
see how their parents interacted with
them a lot and i had this theory of like
from certain countries when they were
immigrant parents
they understood how hard it was to climb
the social ladder let's say
a lot of immigrants start with very
little let's say so their parents
know like you have to study ultra hard
i'm gonna push my kids super duper hard
because we're not gonna we're gonna like
leap frog up
you're not just gonna be a normal person
i'm gonna like train my kid to be
like for instance i grew up i won't say
the towns but uh i used to tutor kids
after
school and stuff with art and whatnot a
lot of asian parents would not let their
kids come home after school
you have piano practice art practice
whatever all kinds of different
practices they would push their kids
you weren't even allowed to come home
you had to go to the library after
school
like i just i noticed the way that they
raised their kids a lot
and the kids resented at first
but then they kicked so much butt as
they get older i do remember you know
when i was a kid like
my mom like drew a picture it said if at
first you don't succeed try try again
and like those message
that messaging i also remember being
like 13 and trying to learn how to
kickflip
and by choice i stood outside my house
for like eight hours every day
kickflip heelflip like skateboard tricks
right so heelflip is when you
pop the board and then with your heel
you kick it and it flips
one day i could just do it it was like
it came naturally to me everybody kind
of has the tricks that just natural it
but kick flip like one of the most basic
tricks everybody can do i struggled with
and no one made me do it there was no
prize there was no no parent sitting
there saying you have to land it
it was just like one day i went outside
my board for eight hours just trying and
i was frustrated i was angry i never get
it made no sense to me
and then i remember the first day i
finally landed it and i landed it
crooked and i was like yeah i did it
no one told me to do it there was no i
wasn't forced to i got no prize for it
other than my own
so i wonder you know i think i think
everything's a little bit of nature and
nurture yeah
and for me especially there was i don't
i don't think there was something in my
life that
i i can't recall other than maybe just
being around hard-working parents
that maybe i don't realize how much that
really buff on me but there's a lot
about
me obviously where i'm just like i have
to do it it has to be perfect yeah it's
similar with me and drawing and stuff
and i'm sure sheamus you can agree
there's a certain satisfaction to
setting a goal for yourself
oh yeah and then realizing wait i did
that but nobody
taught me how to do it there's just some
miracle of
uh this feeling of hard work
equals results and if i keep doing this
one thing over and over like i'm a huge
fan of the ten thousand hour rule let's
say yeah
if anyone asks me how do i get good at
drawing it's like well have you drawn
ten thousand hours
get started or yeah continue down the
road um but that lesson
i don't think it's necessarily racial in
the sense of like it can be passed from
parents
to kids or something like that you're i
don't think so maybe some people are
born with it some aren't but
i don't like that um there's a cultural
excuse
of where i'm born in a position where
uh let's say some people are more ahead
of me than i am
i don't like the excuse of uh well i'm
just not going to try because i
was given a bad hand at birth or uh
that's that's the narrator to the left
man but it's not your fault don't try
but it's such a lie it's such a you're
you're playing yourself if you think
that you are
not in control of your future if you
keep trying
to do something just one thing pick one
thing you love yeah
just keep doing it and eventually like
i didn't make my br my big break or
whatever in cartooning until two years
ago
i'd been drawing i made my debut or
whatever back in 2006.
exactly i couldn't get a job in comics
until two years ago
it takes a lot a lot of people don't
know this but before sheamus started
freedom tunes it was commie tunes it was
coming too
i was actually a far left activist and
then i was like all right i'm gonna try
to be a little bit more moderate so i
made biden tunes
and i've said this before which is huge
which is good which is better which was
good
but then at one point i was like you
know what i've got an idea let's try
freedom tunes and i
i'm here today but um i mean i agree
with you
um it's funny because no it takes a
really long time to become successful in
anything and for me
it wasn't just drawing i mean i'm pretty
mediocre at just like the raw art of
like drawing something photo realistic
i'm much more into cartooning i used to
be
a lot better at drawing in college when
i was doing it consistently but the
point is for me the payoff was trying to
see how quickly i could get
something done that looked decent and
that skill set
obviously turned out to pay out for me
because uh because we're uploading stuff
all the time and that's a huge strategy
for our growth but
yeah i hear that in on the other hand
there's very much a nurture component to
it how much were you pushed as a kid to
not give up
how many virtues reinstilled with but
there is a nature part of it which is
how interested are you in the thing to
begin with
exactly i think parents can can give
kids drive
i think absolutely if parents just make
their kids stick to something it helps
and whatever gets your butt in that seat
for ten thousand hours honestly
that that's a sorry oh i was told that i
could do it
which is why i believed i could
otherwise i never would have tried okay
my parents never
and like they never pushed me to do art
or actually like it's a funny thing
i was told your parents never pushed you
to do
nobody pushed me i'm giving you a heart
i mean i think most people's parents are
like please don't do art do anything
besides art
my whole life it's been that story no
for real like i was i tried to go to art
school and they're like why don't you go
to like real school
exactly can you get a real degree and
then just do art on the side but there
was just something in me that
said i have to do this and this this is
the only thing i can do
i'm not good at anything else this is
one of the i think one of the biggest
problems with
modern society especially for young
people is the obsession with college
so after occupy wall street and i'm
featured in i get i get all this press
on featured in magazines
i still had family being like will you
go to college now yeah and i was like
no no no no no i'm going to college
right now i'm on my way where are you
25. okay i was like i'm going to college
right now
i'm on my way to give a guest lecture to
the phd course on journalism yeah i was
like what do you what do you think i
would learn when i'm the one being
brought in to like teach these people
things they don't know
stephen colbert got an honorary degree
after he was just stephen colbert the
goofball on tv
they were like we love him so much we're
gonna give him a college degree for that
i know art school dropouts who
they dropped out of art school and then
later they got a degree honorary degree
something like that and they ended up
teaching at that school
well that's a weird thing you should
really only go to it for the skills
you're going to pick up the degree
probably
that and networking yeah networking is
the the biggest advantage too
we we kind of veered off in this
direction i wanted to stop before and
move into the ramifications of
having a world world view built upon you
can't succeed
because the world is the problem so one
of the one of the key things is like
core elements of the culture war one
side says you can do better
and you know find your path towards
victory the other side says
there is no path because the world is
bad and the world must change for you
yeah which brings me to this story from
the daily mail quote
it's like living in palestine
minneapolis is renamed
murderapolis as children under poli of
under police city pay the price and
blood for violence
that has skyrocketed since the death of
george floyd
so they go on to mention 211 people have
suffered gunshot wounds up from 81 last
year
more than 200 cops have left or are
leaving signing off for on disability
more than 300 people uh gathered at the
site of aeneas fatal shooting for a
peace walk a call from the community to
put down the guns and pick up the love
what's happening now is i've experienced
occupy wall street i've experienced it
with these activists
when you keep telling people over and
over again there's literally nothing you
can do to succeed
what happens people don't give up
believe it or not they don't succeed but
some people decide okay then then i'll
take
then you get crime you get violence then
they demand the system change
and you know we see a lot of these
stories about police brutality and and
police shootings
there's a story right now so in
minneapolis the other night they were
rioting why
because of an armed fugitive who was
arrested like 20 times and had multiple
felonies
u.s marshals tried to stop him they said
he drew a gun they shot and killed him
of course then they start rioting and
one guy is caught on camera
and they ask him what he's here for and
he says believe it or not i forgot the
guy's name he's like i'm not gonna lie i
don't remember the guy's name
they clearly have no idea what they're
talking about the own
so so in a sense it's kind of sad they
don't know why they're doing what
they're doing other than it's the only
thing they were
told they could do to affect change
these are people who were never told
when they were younger
you got to keep trying until you figure
it out if if you're if you're trying to
find a path towards victory it's not
working try a new path these are people
who are told there isn't one
you will never succeed and so what do
they do they
they just go out and smash exactly i
mean and that's a huge cause of crime
right people believing that there's
nothing they can do to improve their
material circumstances within the system
they have to break the rules in order to
get ahead
and so if your view of the world is that
the only way you're ever going to make
something of yourself or achieve any
level of
status is by hurting other people guess
what you're going to hurt other people
you're going to take their stuff
or just destroy things and burn it down
because because your body can't have it
no one have
no one can have it well you're just in
her you're hurting the insurance
companies you're not yeah exactly
i'm sorry i'm so glad insurance was
invented so we could just burn down
anything for any reason and no one gets
hurt there's no victim
people well i just want to mention this
about insurance there are people
who have literally gone into debt
just cleaning up the debris from their
place of work or the business they own
being destroyed in a riot
and the insurance check didn't even
cover that so they went into debt
without even getting to reopen their
business our insurance will pay for
let's not forget
you ever go to a pizza restaurant and
you see a picture of like the the owner
and he's
like tony danza and he's giving me a
thumbs up that photo's never coming back
you can't get insurance for that
photograph but let's let's be a little
less silly
less silly the first dollar everyone
frames their first dollar they put up on
the wall
yeah the first hour that comes in never
getting that back let's say the guy had
a painting from his mom on the wall
never getting that back let's say his
mom
died and the last thing she gave him
after she died was this beautiful
painting and he says i want to i want to
see this painting
every day in my shop and they threw a
brick through his window and they burned
it down
insurance will never pay for that
exactly and also profit margins are very
thin so even if you're lucky enough to
have your insurance company pay for it
your rates are going to increase and
it's possible your rates will increase
so much that you're not going to afford
to operate in that area
anymore so fewer people are going to
open shop in that area the only people
will be able to afford to will be
massive businesses
so you're just hurting the little guy in
the end yeah
this is this is what happens when you
know
people are told throughout their whole
life there is nothing
and that's that's the danger of this
white privilege i i ideology these
leftists they talk about white privilege
like uh we talked about this last week
or whatever when chris ruffo was
challenged by that guy mark lamont hill
because you know he was saying they're
trying to say whiteness is all bad and
then mark lamont hill is like i think
that was
it was michael might not think his name
and he's like tell me one good thing you
like about being white and chris roofer
was like i reject that framework
like as if race is the component and
he's right
that that dude who is interviewing him
views the world
through you by nature of being white
have something
this is critical race theory that
whiteness is property
that's that's literally what they think
they think that you're walking around
with like plus two charisma
because you you started as a white
person racial passives
yeah exactly like as if you have like a
little book you open it up and it's like
white it means you get plus one all
stats and plus one money it's like it
doesn't work that way
it doesn't you you have to be a good
person and it's the weirdest thing that
that they attribute it to white people
because imagine it this way let's say a
baby is born in the in the middle of the
woods and the mom dies
and then wolves come and and take the
baby and the baby's raised by wolves
is that baby going to have privilege no
it's not it's it's going to be living
with wolves and eating refuse
look it has that's the kind of argument
that somebody who doesn't
care about history or is intentionally
not
all right so i'm greek right my
great-grandparents were
having to deal with the ottoman empire
we don't
it's not a modern thing that a lot of
people talk about but they were
basically on the run
refugees some of my extended family back
then might have even been like slaves
who knows
and then they were on the run for many
years and eventually they made their way
to america whatever
that had nothing to do with race it was
just a terrible thing that happened to
a certain region of the world that there
were
bad people doing things to people who
were just trying to live their lives
kind of thing it's terrible
but i use the example of this like i'm
first generation american i was born
here
i had opportunities that my parents
didn't have that my grandparents
definitely didn't have like my grandma
was picking tobacco as a girl
you know she's telling me about like her
hands were brown because she's like she
was picking up all this tobacco like a
girl she didn't have a childhood
my grandpa same thing didn't finish
middle school
i got to finish high school it's it's
just a straight like
i'm so it drives me nuts to think like
i didn't realize this until i was a an
adult but just to have been born here is
such a lucky thing for me compared to
the rest of my family
just one generation ago my dad i i don't
want to talk too much about him out of
respect but like
he was born in like terrible conditions
and just the fact that he made it to
america at
all is such a freak accident and then
for me to have been born here it's even
more of a freak accident
but then for me to go around and i can't
blame all right let's say my
career didn't work out until recently
whatever i can't blame anybody but
myself for that
i didn't work hard enough i didn't have
the right opportunities whatever maybe i
had bad luck
but i i was born in america and that's
already not to disrespect anyone who
wasn't but like
just to be born here but in this time in
this time that's what's going on yeah it
makes you
so lucky because because you realize if
if this
if we were doing this show if we were
trying to do the show maybe like seven
years ago sheamus would be surrounding
me with a bunch of his with with all his
buddies pouring milkshakes on my head
and like laughing
no it would be the opposite dude the
irish would be getting made
unlocked no i mean it's true that like
the irish were extremely lower
class and i know that my grandfather on
my
mom's side was basically pulled out of
school in fourth grade so that was the
highest education he ever gotten he just
had to work for the rest of his
childhood in america
yeah in america okay in america so
things and also i won't get too into
the details of my family history but a
lot of really horrible
horrible circumstances that just befell
my uh
pretty recent ancestors even in this
nation this is an incredible time to be
alive and also when i look at where my
ancestors were just one or two
generations ago
and where i am now it's really
incredible that people could work their
way up any kind of hierarchy that
quickly over time
because in many other countries you just
have a kind of caste
system and people look at the united
states and they say well there is a
hierarchy and so that must mean you have
kind of a caste system the richer at the
top poor at the bottom
but what people don't recognize is that
there is so much
there is so much moving in and out of
income brackets in the united states
that is entirely unprecedented
historically and also in the world today
there's more economic
mobility in the united states than any
other country in the world but
you will never be told you're only told
about income inequality you're not told
about the fact that people move
through their income bracket extremely
fluidly in the united states
and that just isn't the case to the same
extent in other developed countries and
even our low income brackets like the
fact that we have like air conditioning
in our houses that you could pay for an
air conditioner or whatever
that you can go and buy groceries half
the world can't buy groceries half the
time
the fact that you can buy a crappy car
let's even say like that just kind of
runs like puts you already ahead of so
many people yeah
we have we have fat homeless people i
mean
like we've got which is a problem well
yes but in homelessness also often
and i know a number of people are
homeless and it's horrible but
oftentimes homelessness
is a product of mental illness or
alcoholism it's not as if we don't have
enough resources for everybody and you
you also have that uh video
um i tweeted this video out from uh
twitter account on the venice boardwalk
it's three guys just laughing about how
they love being homeless
uh so i worked at a homeless shelter one
of the biggest problems is people don't
we we get this so often from the left
when they're like we could end the
homelessness if we just stop spending
money here i'm like bro you can't
you can't it's it's like children
and i mean this with respect you know
children just lack knowledge
they they're they're young they haven't
experienced things they also lack wisdom
and
it's not absolute there are a lot of
really smart and wise young people for
sure
but they look at homeless people and
they're like we could just pay to end
this and i'm like go
down to venice and ask the beach bums
and they're going to be like i'm not
going anywhere
they're back i like living out here dude
i gotta admit like venice is rad
they got public showers that are
beautiful and tons of people just sleep
on the beach
you can't convince them to stop doing it
because it's it's the it's their passion
they love it
and it's true for other places too
they're they're they're rail rail
jumpers
that whatever they call these people
they ride the rails they ride cargo
trains throughout the united states
and they have you know it's like it's
like that trope of the the hobo with the
stick and he's got the handkerchief
wrapped in the back and it's full of
stuff
not like that specifically but i knew a
ton of people when i lived in seattle
they were they were rail jumpers they
would wait for a cargo freight train and
they would jump on the back and ride it
for free across the u.s
sometimes the train would stop and the
engineers would get out start beating
the crap out of them and chase them off
typically they would just ride for free
across the us they don't want to to not
be homeless
so the solutions to these problems are
not particularly easy and people have to
realize
a lot of it comes down to personal
responsibility and personal choice
well i also want to say this i want to
be really careful here too because there
are a lot of homeless people and i know
homeless people who don't want to be
homeless they wish they had a house and
i see this in the city i live in i also
see this in the chicago area tim i'm
sure you saw this when you were working
at a homeless shelter was it in the
chicago area no no
okay so obviously there different parts
of the world have different problems
with homelessness but
in chicago where it's freezing out i
mean a lot of those people they really
wish they had a home and they don't
but that's not necessarily a product of
the fact
that there weren't enough resources for
everyone i mean we have multiple empty
homes for every homeless person
it's also that a lot of these people are
really seriously mentally ill
right or have a very serious addiction
problem and just putting them in a house
is not a solution to that problem they
have to be monitored people need to be
taking care of them
or they need to be in a mental health
facility somewhere so there's more that
we have to be doing for these people but
it's often made out to be this
this problem we could solve by just
throwing enough money at the right
people or just placing them in these
empty houses that are already there and
it's totally naive
once again like i say children you know
people who have never owned a home yeah
or been responsible for a home so look
two days ago the the a lot this fire
alarm went off
and so everybody has to get up fire
apartment comes we leave we leave the
house
so lightning struck the other day and
our internet broke so something happened
we don't
this was this was you know after the
outage but something happened that may
have fried some electrical circuit we
don't know there was a storm before this
and so when the smoke alarm went off we
were worried there may have been
something
internally some wiring that tripped it
we couldn't
i swept the house couldn't find anything
and we're like what are we supposed to
do
so we call them they come did a sweep
turns out we're good hopefully we're
good
maybe it wasn't lightning that struck it
maybe there was an electrical fire on
one of these cables or something that we
didn't realize and that's what made the
alarm go off maybe it wasn't lightning i
don't know
but i i recognize that having to
maintain this house and have to be
responsible for people's safety
now imagine you took a homeless person
and just put them in this building and
said it's an empty house there you go
the alarm goes off let's say this
person's not mentally capable of taking
care of the house
and then the house burns down and
they're in it no one calls the 9-1-1 no
one's there for him
you can't just put a person in a house
it doesn't work that way exactly
but let's talk about uh let's talk about
you know i guess
the left and hypocrisy because we got
this uh this story here
uh-oh it's from the other day actually
but it's been picking up
okay boomer tick-tock influencer called
hypocrite
after showing off two million dollar
flat
everybody knows uh nico lol she is an
influencer
and if you're not if you don't know who
she is just take a look at uh george
over here he's got a
a picture that he drew what kind of
freak
you would draw that yeah especially at
top left something's wrong with that
artist yeah who hurt him biden
emerging from the wall like some kind of
gigantic junji ito demon
so what's happening in this in this
piece of art george
well she uh she regrets being
a part of the party that ended up
devouring her i mean she was
obviously supporting one guy and then oh
no it's the other guy
and you fed him turns out you fed him
the whole time there are like
other faces in his body oh yes you see
there's the sequel
my book oh no it's uncle joe which is
not oh no it's not based on anyone real
you see where the story is that uh you
know
there's okay okay so anyway this is uh
she's she's a very popular influencer
she she did this dance she probably saw
it where she's saying okay boomer
gets 50 million views now she's rich the
thing is everybody's dragging her
because she's got a bernie shirt on
she's wearing attacks the rich shirt and
then she makes a video where she's like
my two million dollar apartment
the first thing i'll just say is when
did you expect that
why would you believe that any of these
people actually knew or understood
economics or politics
right like all of these young dsa types
my assumption immediately is that their
children
you know that's why they have that
saying it's like um if you're not
uh conservative when you're older you
have no head if you're not liberal when
you're young you have no heart or
whatever
well i think it's obvious what i was
gonna get and i needed desperately the
money and i look at my check
and i'm like nah this ain't right and i
was like there's something wrong with my
check
and they're like no look there it is all
the breakdowns there and i was like why
am i being taxed so much
like that blew my mind i'm like bro i'm
poor i can't afford that it's insane
they talk about raising the minimum
minimum wage while they're taxing people
who make minimum wage it's like how
about you just take
less of their money oh that's a great
idea yeah i mean they get it back at the
end of the year for the most part if
they're poor
but anyway what ends up happening is you
get you get a lot of people who go to
college they never had a job
yeah so while they're in college they
hear bernie socialism communism and all
the other stuff they've never had a job
then when they get out what happens some
of them become famous
start making hundreds of thousands of
dollars millions of dollars
and now they're just like okay boomer
you know
yeah buy two million dollar flat or
whatever i don't know if you actually
bought it
but they just they never actually
understood any of the politics they were
espousing
because i tell you this any one of these
people if they had to provide for a
family
they'd be like abolish taxes yes
taxation is that 100
the moment they look they're like i just
worked all year and
what do i have to show for it well 40 of
your income i think the total taxes with
sales tax and everything it's like 48
or something like that of your income
goes to the government or higher
with sales tax and also depends on how
you look at it so owes to the government
or higher with sales tax and also
depends on how you look at it so
if you're self-employed or you run your
own business you have to pay more into
social security you pay in what your
employer would normally pay and
what people don't realize is like their
employer when they do pay into that
they're taking that out of that person's
check so you're paying
more into taxes than you actually think
you are so so this is uh this okay
boomer thing right
at first i was actually going to do a
segment where i was like guys
i really don't care that she's rich you
can be you can be a lefty and still
believe in like class and wealth
if you're like octam yeah maybe right
right right and so i'm like there's
there's nuance here maybe she's gonna
learn but then i saw this video where
she's like
she made a video called how much money
do i make and she said i think when
people are talking about the wealthy
they're talking like about billionaires
and i'm like oh here we go that's
hilarious
i'm not so uh here's the thing i made
this joke years ago i did a cartoon
about the um 99.99 complaining about the
0.01 percent
oh oh one percent or 001 percent um and
the whole bit was that in the united
states
where the vast majority of people have a
standard of life significantly higher
than basically everyone else in the
world so if you make more than thirty
thousand dollars a year you're in the
top one percent of the world economy
and people in the u.s are constantly
complaining i shouldn't say all people
knows but many are constantly
complaining about income inequality
and it's literally like to some extent
millionaires complaining
about billionaires not always i
understand when you get into things like
healthcare there are actually a lot of
legitimate problems that need to be
solved there but
i think it's funny that now we literally
do have millionaires complaining about
billionaires like
it's a joke i made years ago and it's an
actual thing which is happening i would
you know you should
you should make a video of with bernie
being like i
am a humble millionaire upset with the
billionaires
look how much i have to work but if you
write a best-selling book you can be a
millionaire
but it's gotta be like he's leading a
rally of millionaires it's a bunch of
millionaires with pitchforks angry at
the best
like i did i i made a cartoon like that
years ago
and it was it was these rich guys
complaining about how other people are
more rich than them it is unfair and now
that i have to write
an entire book to buy my fourth house
there might be something to it because
the founding fathers of the united
states were basically millionaires of
their time
up against the billionaire of their time
the king who was
unfairly you know fiscally robbing them
taxing them
and so these big companies with these
bailouts and
are basically that that's a modern-day
monarchy and maybe
maybe we need a class of millionaires to
rise up and fix things it's
there there is a massive disparity
between the wealthiest and the poorest
in the world that's like we've never
seen before
so what happens is in the us you end up
with these like
what are we calling a silver spoon
socialists where
there's someone super chat is like okay
yeah so she's a silver socialist where
they're like
supporting bernie sanders and democratic
socialism while they're
millionaires complaining about
billionaires and i'm like dude i think
it's all bad
i get it people are allowed to be rich i
got no problem with people being rich
i'm saying
my problem is with the ultra wealthy
manipulating elections and using undue
influence and everything it's a
challenge i know how you solve it
because it's not just about having money
like the fact that we
that i have the show that we're on the
show is more valuable than money people
pay
so that they can get a message out
across through the show or something so
i don't know how you actually deal with
problems like that but i can tell you
this
someone who's got 50 million dollars has
massive power
and someone with a billion dollars has a
lot more but they can still have massive
influence over over elections
yeah you don't need money to be super
popular and influential
you just need a little bit just put hold
it up no are you sure
this is no don't acceptable don't do it
why not don't do it don't okay
i gotta do it it's gross don't do it can
i don't no shannon
well so this is the funny thing about
niko i'll take your money that's right
i'll i'll draw butts all the time the
the
funny thing about nikola is that people
are commenting
like people like peop people are
dragging her being like you're a
hypocrite and all that stuff
but her fans are like i literally only
follow her for her body i don't care
what she believes
whatever man she's getting rich with
that fine whatever it's her hustle
whatever everybody's got their own
hustle i yeah also
i don't know what we were expecting from
like the tick tocker here at the same
time maybe maybe that's a little kind of
setting i mean what i'm like i'm a
youtuber so maybe i shouldn't be dumping
on tick tockers but
i like to think we're like a little bit
above that i like to think
so i think dragon bernie is perfectly
perfectly appropriate absolutely i do
he stopped saying millionaire when he
became a millionaire no joke like there
was an article it's like you can track
the moment he removed a millionaire from
his speeches and it's around the same
time he became a millionaire
that's the stupidest thing ever welcome
to the club of wanting money like we
were talking about this before we went
on air
i don't see why every young people isn't
saying i want to be a millionaire i want
to
do whatever is morally okay with me
whatever i'm going to do what's
got to be done to earn a living and
maybe earn more than a living so i can
you know take care of my family whatever
buy a nice car if you want to buy a nice
car there's no guilt factor i don't
understand why people have this guilt of
like
it's okay to make money and seriously
have the money and then
you know you can spread it to other
places invest
give it to other people so they can do
things with that money don't just sit on
you know people have this idea of all
right so there's the idea of
if uh certain people who don't have a
lot of money win the lottery it actually
is worse for them in the long run
because they don't know how to spend the
money
or save it or reinvest it but like if
you
i feel like if you have this if you work
for your money
maybe you have a little bit more of uh
you understand the value of that dollar
or something it's like i have a couple
of dollars in my pocket i'm not going to
just let it sit there
i want to make it do something i want to
buy bitcoin
whatever it doesn't matter you got it
the whole point is you've got to try
this idea of when you have a couple of
bucks you don't just sit on it
you don't just waste it you want to try
to do something with it give it to other
people hire other people so that you can
make more money and they can make more
money that
that's the point of that's one of the
good things about earning money so i can
unders
i can understand how you might look at
someone who has a lot and just assume
they're just going to waste it all all
the time but
everybody thinks they should have your
money everybody thinks they should be
rich well that's kind of i mean you
sound a little keynesian for me on the
the point about savings but i hear you i
think what it goes back to is what we
discussed earlier with people thinking
the only reason anyone has money is
because they've done something evil to
get it and if you're at the top of that
hierarchy it must be because you
participated in a rigged game yeah of
course
until they get some yeah until they get
some and then they're like well actually
and then you can become a billion a
millionaire ethically but can
millionaires and then as soon as jeff
bezos becomes a trillionaire it's just
going to be him that everyone's mad at
but
billionaires are going to be like no
being a billionaire is the trillionaires
who are really doing it too
we need a bernie in 10 years and he's
like really old and he's a billionaire
now
because he wrote like he wrote a
thousand new best-selling books and made
a billion dollars and he's like the
multi-billionaires in this country uh
are the problem not not the billionaires
and then it's like jeff he's like he's
like he's looking at his phone
and he's sweating and it says like jeff
business net worth and it's at 999
billion
and then it rolls over to one trillion
he goes the trillionaires in this
country
well here's the great thing about joe
biden's administration and what
what uh our political leaders decided to
do with printing all this money we might
all be millionaires soon yeah
look at that i can't wait you guys want
to see something crazy
oh that hyperinflation is let me let me
let me pull some up for you guys all
right check this out we got the you ever
see the us debt clock
yes i just i can't even look at it it's
a real time
let's check it out check this out tim
why are you doing this too the u.s debt
clock dot org
says savings per family 36
875 dollars
the the average savings per family so
that means grab a random family in new
york they got thirty six
thousand dollars in their main account
that's a lot of money right sounds
wrong but that's i don't know if that
because that used to be a lot of money
so
but hold on that's not average because
don't they say like oh because certain
families have 100
600 it says or unseen expense so the
well just it's the average not not the
media liquid cash in personal savings
for all u.s families divided by the
number of u.s families okay so there's a
small group of them that are
super rich and then everybody else uh i
i don't think there's enough rich people
to skew it that heavily
but it's probably like okay so maybe the
the the median for the
like middle class probably like 20k or
or whatever so
uh but let me let me let me jump over
here we have this button look at this
button right here it says
debt clock time machine oh no and i'm
going to click this and i'm going to
jump to 2025.
let me ask you oh what do you think the
average savings per family will be
by twenty twenty five hundred and seven
hundred a hundred and seven hundred and
seventeen
based on the inflation we're seeing now
hundred and seven all right answers what
do you think george
um sure from 108
your price is
by taking the current the current
tracking and the current numbers jumping
four years from now says that if you
divide take the total number of
liquid cash in all savings and divided
by the number of families the average is
half a million dollars that's pretty bad
so and here's the thing oh but that's a
big number right that means
like i said we're all millionaires so
think about this wait wait that means
if one bitcoin right now costs thirty
six thousand dollars one bitcoin in 2025
will be worth half a million dollars
that's a lot of oh man in here that's a
lot of i'm gonna buy bitcoin well here's
here's the ceilings to buy for your
grandma
here's what's um excuse me here's what's
really scary about this so this is the
the projected numbers by 2025 but
i mean look back in 2016 no one no one
would have predicted that by 2021 we'd
be 28 trillion in debt so
it could be far worse by 2025. inflation
in
2016 the national debt was 19 trillion
19. yeah it was just under 20
27. and yeah now we're 28 28 dude
by 2025 the national debt is projected
to be
50 trillion which is good
that's fine that's fine everything's
okay well you can see how it manifests
512 000 savings per family what people
need to understand that means
right now what's happening somebody's
like i got 36k in the bank
why do i need to work i'm good so then
in order to get people to work
mcdonald's is offering a thousand dollar
sign-on bonus
in order to pay for that sign-on bonus
those increase wages they charge more
for burgers
it just makes everything cost more yeah
exactly so right now there's the bitcoin
conference going on have you guys seen
this yeah
i think max down there someone yeah yeah
he walks in everyone's like
standing ovation and he was yelling and
he's like f elon or something like that
it was hilarious
and uh there's a big dumpster outside of
it that says tr uh cash is trash
and it's full of venezuelan you know
boulevard yes
or whatever so people were actually
making
paper art out of their venezuelan marks
and selling it online so they would make
like
bags and wallets and sell those on the
internet to get a higher return on their
money than they would have just
converting it to dollars
interesting so when you google it
it's uh uh what pops up is our good
friend
luke rodkowski oh he says there's free
venezuelan bolivars in a dumpster at the
bitcoin conference
that's not except they require energy to
acquire so nothing's free
i think you know i would take a bunch of
those as well
oh i'd be like bro i mean we're fighting
over toilet paper right now
like come on they're giving away for
free wood costs a lot yeah i think it's
made of plastic though
but either way it's like boxes and boxes
of boulevards just in a dumpster
you're the craziest thing is because
like i've been to venezuela you we had
we had a big black garbage bag
full of the money and i was like what's
the point dude just bring a ten dollar
bill from america to buy your pizza
otherwise i'm like
some guy a garbage bag thrown in his
trunk and eventually you're just like
dude i didn't want to carry it's not
even worth the carry
yeah fiat well they keep printing all
this money joe biden
is 22 trillion in borrowing 6 trillion
in spending
so what do you think is going to happen
to the economy what does that mean where
is he borrowing that
from and what's he where so he's he's
issuing another 22
million trillion borrow from the federal
reserve is that what this is i mean the
borrowing probably is bonds
and loans etc debts so it could be like
you know they pledge to pay something
and then track an invoice
but they're going to knock our debt from
28 trillion to 50 trillion with this
by the time joe biden leaves office
after his first term because you know
he will and donald trump has already
issued an email
where he said the next time i'm in
office we are going to be
nearly double the national debt 50
trillion
that's amazing i remember when they were
like the debt ceiling and the
the national debt is too high and now
it's just like deficit spend deficit
spend until nothing is worth nothing and
everybody just you know
lives off of saltine crackers basically
yeah 50 trillion that's going to be
fantastic
well it just means look i think the
economy will keep on churning
but uh your savings is gone so if you
have us dollars right now this is why
people are buying uh
you know houses like crazy but i'll tell
you what man
uh so i got a message today from
the the uh jessica who does our graphic
design stuff [ __ ] she had a photo
i think it was starbucks and they were
like we're out of we're out of peaches
we're out of strawberries we're out of
fruit we're on a coffee we're out of
this right at that it was like
a sign they're like we don't got nothing
so they keep saying supply hasn't caught
up yet
and i'm like then why is the shortage
why are the shortages getting worse
you know like maybe joe biden keeps
paying people not to work and printing
money like crazy and uh
i don't know i'm looking for a silver
lining here you can i don't know why
okay buy silver well that's financial
advice i would never give
everyone just kidding friendly
suggestions by silver that's not what i
said that's financial advice too
if i ask you for financial advice can
you give it to me as a friend
ran away even if you're not a finance
manager sheamus
in my time of need seamus is just
chugging all of this while he's like a
gallon of water he's hot
look you guys i wasn't intending to give
financial advice
i didn't that's a silver lining
right now right now the average savings
for family 36k
price of bitcoin 36k coincidence maybe
but if inflation is is gonna track
savings bitcoin's going to be at half a
million by 2025. i think it'll be higher
it'll be higher yeah because it's not
just not financial advice
because listen listen bitcoin tracking
just for inflation half a million
but add on the fact that it's going to
be more widespread yeah so at this
bitcoin conference it was crazy someone
posted a video where the line was like
blocks and blocks long to get in bitcoin
is legit here man
yeah elon musk can cry as much you can
cry all day and night about it posters
little silly memes
and nobody cares people were like
posting they were gonna sell off tesla
stock they don't want to be involved
because tesla is playing dirty games or
whatever
or because elon is but i think
if if it's tracking just for inflation
half a million for a bitcoin
you add in the fact that we got four
years of bitcoin growth and you got
development million dollars two million
dollars per bitcoin
and then people are going to wish they
had some that's not financial advice
no i don't don't buy don't no that's
financial i know
don't do anything just just don't listen
to me is that financial
don't listen to people to invest in
freedom tunes t-shirts
if i ask someone to buy something um i
think this is not financial advice but
if you want a freedom tunes t-shirt just
go to freedomtunesmerch.com
there's a t-shirt i think you're allowed
you're allowed to suggest them to buy
them but not to invest in them
it's not an investment all right now
here's the thing the money you have
might be worth less in the future and
you could have got a t-shirt out of it
but you won't be able to it'll be too
late so
freedomtunes.com uh or
freedomtunes.merch i'm sorry
freedomtunesmerch.com
financial advice i can't even get a
domain name right bro this is
freedomtunesmerch.com
this this bitcoin conference was lit
because like not only did they have the
venezuelan dollars in the dumpster
not only was it jam-packed with people
who are super enthusiastic about this
decentralized currency
but laura loomer confronted jack dorsey
and i'm i'm all here for you what's
there jack dorsey who's the jack dorsey
was speaking and she really
and she got up she got up and she's like
you're manipulating elections
and then i guess she got you know
security throughout or whatever but i'm
like
that's excellent so you've both taken
him to school
oh i mean laura has gone after everybody
she chained her
she handcuffed herself to the twitter
building in new york really yeah
yeah so that's you know i just yelled at
the guy i guess like
i argued with him he had his bodyguard
that was when tim and i met i asked him
to do a voice in the cartoon i made
about you yelling at jack dorsey
yeah i was unaware of everything that
was being done
oh yeah we got we haven't discriminated
against conservatives if we want people
to be free on our platform
that's the only way and then who did the
voice of uh vajayagarh
i think it was me yeah i didn't like i
couldn't do an impression of her so i
just did like a generic bad female voice
i was like well actually
that we have to the reason the website
did this but uh i was more i mean the
jack
the twitter exists to just make sure all
conservatives
can rot in hell i just the only way
people are free to speak is
if conservatives can't talk it's just
the only possible solution
no i think they genuinely believe that a
run-of-the-mill conservative
is like you know when they when they
imagine
a regular conservative it's like a
liberal like ezra klein
that's how they see conservatives well
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a line from
michael knowles here but
as he says uh or to put it in his words
the only thing conservatives have been
able to agree on since the cold war is
to cut taxes
and so i think to many people on the
left like that's just what conservatism
is like conservatives when you call it
like talk about tax cuts but everything
else is just that's
weird alt-right what something what is
right-wing anymore
yeah dude nazis were right-wing i heard
ian was right-wing and i was like that's
not correct i know
what is that what is this topsy-turvy
world now i don't understand why i
honestly i hang out with him
is literally a long-haired freaky people
you know i'm i try to be centered but i
mean i'm
drawn to the left i'm drawn to the
wicked wacky wild
you know psychoactive experience of
reality it's not right-wing at all
it's like not even that's one of the
least right-wing things i've ever heard
in my life that's what i'm talking about
tim castillo's a far-right podcast
hosted by a liberal and some weird
hippie guy as soon as i'm off air ian's
like telling me i need to like read
aquinas and
people don't realize it's a wig is it
well that's actually crazy too man's got
a very
short haircut it's funny that that's
also considered right wing now like it's
just it's
it's just strange how all like the
foundational philosophy of our culture
is
scary and dangerous i suppose jesus was
probably left-wing
would have been considered left-wing for
his time like he was he was a radical
anti-establishment you know he spoke out
against the empire
so yeah real quick yeah speaking out
against the empire what do you think
and the caps are they're not left-wing
yeah
like the bitcoin conference is loaded
with libertarians the left and the right
thing
exactly well here's the thing and this
is why we have to be very careful
real quick sorry sorry just yeah left
literally means evil that's all you need
to know
yeah basically no that's that's what i'm
trying to say but no i mean kind of
because here's the thing we view
everything as left verse right when it
comes to our social structures right now
but these were not terms that were used
prior to the french revolution
and so you kind of have to stop trying
to put different
moments in history into those boxes i
know that the left
literally exists and existed from the
very beginning to counter
the catholic church and its goals if you
look at the french revolutions what they
did
yeah yeah if you look at the french
revolution and the foundational thinkers
of it and the foundational thinkers of
leftism their entire purpose has always
been to counter
christian values and more specifically
the catholic church and its goals i got
i got
i was wrong it doesn't mean evil okay i
looked at it i just have uh
adam online etymology left means
opposite of right from old english lift
which means weak and foolish
oh my gosh i'm not kidding and also uh
the dutch dialect loofe meaning weak and
worthless
wow and sinister and also if someone
goes away they left
yeah there you go ah that's all bad at
such a nice they say the usual old
english
win stray whenestra left left hand
literally friendlier a euphemism used
superstitiously to avoid invoking the
unlucky forces connected
with the left side compare sinister
and there you go i would suggest we
don't put ourselves in the same
position that the french revolutionaries
found themselves in
dividing people into a left and a right
dude sinister literally means to the
left
yes it does it means contrary false
unfavorable to the left and the word sin
well i could have told you yeah and the
right literally means right
correct you are right that's busted so
saying someone is far right you're
saying like you are very correct
you're very correct you're very correct
i agree with you very much no i disagree
with you because you're right i'm wrong
incorrect
that's that's all you got to say from
now on people are like you know you're
far right be like thank you i am correct
i am i am very right in all of my
opinions like they are correct they are
right and you're wrong
there's so many like common words like
right left wrong
uh right light heavy dark
light like this word the word light and
the word right
have so many there's so such simple
proliferative words in our language but
have vastly different meanings yeah
depending on how you're using it
i don't like it it's not enough words we
need different words for those
just make stuff yeah looking up the
origin of light and it's not related
light dark or it also means light not
heavy i
it comes from loot light brightness
this is the word light that's it special
light means right
there you go light makes right well
no i don't i don't like that direction
you're going in ian all right thanks
pull me back from the edge
i saw him buying a pack of skittles
earlier
should we i think humans really prefer
light because we're so visually oriented
i think
definitely well it was because darkness
was like night time was scary yeah you
know there's like bears and stuff you're
like
sleeping and you're like you know mind
your own business and like a bear comes
out and like bites you
we really are in this goes back to what
we're talking about earlier like the
americans being born here is such a
like a just valuable in and of itself
and i was thinking just talking earlier
today about how it's kind of like being
in the the king's court like as
americans if the if the earth was a
kingdom we were the ones that were born
in in our living court drama
right now this is all that's going on
inside the castle it's really well let's
be let's be real like
you know ian when we were about to when
we were choosing our characters for the
simulation like we all chose easy mode
basically we were like let's put on
casual you know american and ian chose
white male 1
just absolutely determine what's our
best ending just
help as many people as i can beat it
then maybe i'll i'll try it on hard mode
late next time yeah and hard mode would
be what being born in like somalia
and today it would be yeah yeah or you'd
be born in like the middle of australia
i guess to like a witch doctor family of
like
weird european settlers who found
themselves in the middle of the
outback and you're fighting scorpions
and kangaroos at the same time and
kangaroos that throw scorpions at you
they carry them in their pouches
the worst and then once you like
once you get close enough to the cities
the kangaroos are now like pink they're
like the same animations but they're 10
times stronger
because the simulation didn't feel like
making new monsters yeah
that's just the reality of it elite
kangaroos
they're purple if you guys see the video
where the kangaroos at the guy's window
like banging trying to dude yes
that's terrifying it's all riffs this is
why australians need
guns they go don't know why they got
room can you imagine a kangaroo just
banging on your door i don't know what
i'd do
if i didn't have my weapons aren't like
i'm not i'm sorry i'm not gonna do a
fist fight with a kangaroo nope
have you ever been friends with
kangaroos i thought like in australia
like kangaroos are like people you know
i don't think i watched a video where
they were okay australia went to war
with emus didn't they
in laws what they did no one can beat
them
what happened i need to double check
this i saw a video where like people had
a barbecue and a kangaroo just like
jumps in and everyone's like hey mate
and the kangas is like doing this thing
or something
awesome it's like bouncing around yeah
they so so
they're not that nice to animals
australia did go to war with emus and
they did loose they did lose the world
they were just passed all across
australia fun fact you learn something
new every day
what is an emo i'm pretty anti-war but i
might be able to get behind the emu war
unfortunately they did lose though it
was funny when
sydney watson was here and she told ian
about drop bears yeah and it was all
like whoa
but they were fake yes there's no drop
she took me for a ride what did she
what was she saying drop bears were so
like it's a joke that australians have
to trick non-australians where they
claim that koala bears will like
drop from the trees and land on you and
like maul you or something
drop bears i'm not a position to deny or
i believe it right
so they have like big onion rings i'm
not gonna like question the lived
experience of someone who's come to my
country from a foreign steakhouse and
fosters beer
that's a good question is it like
cultural appropriation uh foster is yes
i think
isn't in australia though i think right
yeah not there it's australian for beer
but it's not australian it's like the
irish people get angry at guinness
which is too bad because that's a great
beer yeah here's here's the here's the
secret y'all have never had a real
goodness
unless you've actually yeah the guinness
that's in ireland is different when they
ship it over it actually messes with the
consistency i had one in dublin
yeah they do the there you go that's the
real one they do
legit you know guinness gives out only
to the people in ireland the history of
guinness
is pretty interesting the the irish dock
workers didn't have any money they were
making beer and then they'd sell
all the beer would be gone at the bottom
of the barrel there'd be this dark
sludge and they didn't have any money so
they just started making beer out of the
sludge
of course we'll drink it it's alcohol
it's like at the bottom yeah of course
we'll try it it became one of the most
delicious
you know beer in my opinion on the
planet probably i love that our
contribution was the bottom of the bag
that's a racist racist stereotype
british people actually drink more per
capita than irish people do
is that true yeah i was reading about it
it's the guilt and the show the irish
drunk emerged because
this is what i heard it could be false
that when
irish immigrants were coming to the
united states like in the early 1900s
and like late 1800s
they would pretend to be drunk if they
were homeless so they can get a free
night's sleep in the in the local jail
oh i know that i know that they're
called paddy wagons because irish people
were disproportionately arrested but
i don't know about that they're like i
was pretending of course i was just
pretending so i could go off to jail for
the night i had
why did someone were to sleep people
just snacks i'm totally
just presentings have had too much
alcohol in
my system right now people do it now
though people
people like homeless people will commit
a low-level crime to get a free place to
stay that's so sad
yeah so sad you occasionally get people
that claim that they're uh
i can't make this joke i was gonna say
they complain that they can't breathe in
order to get taken to the hospital
it's not really it's not a joke that's
the worst part true yeah oh yeah
people feign medical illness when
they're being arrested so they get taken
often
that was that was testimony oh all right
so then
that makes it just harder to deal with
everything and then you get young people
who don't understand how the world works
and they're like burn it down
and then they literally go and burn it
down and they forgot the name of the guy
they were fighting for
they were fighting for a guy named sony
as they walk out with a 50-inch flat
screen under their arm
yeah there was there was looting and and
fires the other day
in minneapolis in the no go zone and
around it after they put it back
up yeah it was after they shot a guy the
marshals killed a fugitive
and so they were like let's go riot and
then unicorn right this lefty group like
interviewed a guy and he's like i'll be
honest i don't even know the
guy's name i can't remember and they're
like his name was like winston i think
or something
yeah i can't remember his name but then
he was like i don't even know his name
and like you're you're torching stuff in
the street like don't you think it's
kind of important you know
the joke i made was like could you
imagine if you showed up for like a
business meeting you're like i'm on the
50th floor for a business meeting and
who are you meeting
i don't know no idea like sir you can't
come in
like you're not here for any particular
reason that's the nature of
of activism these days though guys i
guess one of you can just draw a picture
about it and then we'll carry on as if
nothing happened
act first figure it out later that's
what i figured i'd say
well you know we could do we can take
super chats from
the audience and uh if you haven't
already smash the like button i'm i'm
i'm very excited you know we had some
internet hiccups early on but uh so far
this
squirrels have not chewed through the
line that's just like on the ground
leading outside so i'm like i'm waiting
for a car to run over i don't even
i don't know i guess the guy made it
work so you know good on him we want to
run some tape electrical tape over it
because it's going over the sidewalk
yeah it is yeah actually i think i think
that's the course is gonna go
all the way down to the street or
something i don't i didn't check it
looked like it might though
yeah and then i just driving over it
right now
the internet is gonna run over by a car
anyway smash the like button if you
haven't already done so thanks for
hanging out everybody
christina h says did y'all see tom
mcdonald's new music video today
it was fire blair white isn't it happy
friday i saw clips it's on instagram
it's cool
all right rob lowe robslow says
regarding your members show last night i
will say the whole thing
the whole having a kid kills your dreams
argument is not true as a father
the moment i laid eyes on my daughter
all of my mistakes meant nothing
and all i saw was the future there you
go
that's beautiful ethan randall says
happy kill dowser day
oh is that is it the anniversary of the
day yep oh well
all right let's see politicalbad says
you see blair white was in tom
mcdonald's new music video
snowflakes we need to support non-woke
artists like tom g
prime and freedom tunes thank you that's
correct this is actually
something you mentioned earlier about
like going off to art school and i sort
of joked about how
how parents generally don't like that or
don't like their kid pursuing a career
in art i just want to say this
if you're a conservative person and you
like are upset about the fact that
conservatives are not represented in
artistic careers
you got to become comfortable with your
kid going into one yes
and conservative artists should also
feel emboldened even though i don't like
that word like
you see sheamus there you see to a
smaller extent myself
there aren't a lot of conservative
artists for some reason it's like we're
scared of getting canceled or something
if we don't step up and i mean there's
this stereotype a cliche of like a lot
of
artists and cartoonists and even
humorists are left-leaning but like
where are all the right-leaning or even
middle slash
conservative creators like it's
a step forward it's because there needs
to be a sufficient tribe for money to
exist
and what happens on the left is there's
a massive market for leftism
and so it's basically a mexican standoff
they may not believe these
things but they're like i'm not going to
cross this group that pays me i'll get
too much flack it's not worth it the
same thing exists on the right
yeah 100 i mean somehow we've got to be
able to find
the time to do this x hours per week
let's say if this is a full-time job at
least 40 hours a week for me it's like
60.
yeah but like i'm trying my best and a
lot of us are trying our best we just
got to try to find the money to do this
i don't know like
all right so a lot of left-leaning
creators like they had the daily show
and stuff like that they have actual
late night shows where they have you
know back in commercials and all that
stuff
people paying them to do their snl right
like what happened to comedy i don't
know
but they're not funny anymore they
haven't been funny for 20 years but like
all right so those people are getting
paid to do their
thing and uh conservative creators i
think if more of us step
up and if you have the guts to step up
don't be afraid of being canceled
because if you're working for yourself
kind of you can't be canceled
i i feel like there's just got to be
more of us and uh
and more high quality stuff i'm not
saying you can you you can still be
canceled but to a lesser degree right
like
if you work for a company and you cross
the left they'll fire you from your job
yeah if you work for the right and you
say something out of turn they'll
probably just
like argue with you and it might be bad
for you in the long run
but you know you can get canceled on the
right yeah it happens you can have
clients refuse to work with you in the
future if you're self-employed you could
also just be completely de-platform
true i mean that happened but i know but
i agree completely with your message
completely somehow we've got to find a
way to make a living at this
fine but there are a lot of us who want
to do this for a living we just
some somehow there's got to be a
connection between finding an audience
and then just
giving them something that they're
willing to throw you a tip or something
yeah
i hear you here's some money for
t-shirts right here's the super chat
speaking of which super chats
john easton says he got three questions
so we'll go with the first one
do you guys think that anime and eastern
cartoons have become popular due to the
decline in quality in western shows yes
well i'll answer this first i i grew up
watching anime because
american shows are like episodic
and anime is like you know what's it
called like a serial yes continuous
and so watching like dragon ball z
growing up
what happens next and they always live
in the cliffhanger you know like goku's
about to go super saiyan you're like i
gotta see the next episode oh man
and you have this really long story
where someone asks you like what's
happening in this episode oh dude you
gotta watch a hundred episodes to figure
out what's happening here
and then american shows it was like at
the end of every every show it just
restarts
yes it's just like nothing changes and
it was just gag humor
and i wasn't a big end of it i don't
know what do you guys think
do you want to go first no no you go
ahead well there's a lot of history i've
been studying the history of comics for
a long time because i
uh before i did silly political strips i
was trying to get into indie comics
again
and um if you study sort of what
happened to american comics in the past
few decades
there was a massive bubble in 92-93 so
image comics around 92 when spawn was
coming out and it was getting formed was
like
the peak of american comics since i want
to say the 50s 40s something like that
the golden age in the silver age was
happening so then the bubble burst for
various reasons and then there was a lot
of
stores closing in the mid to late 90s
because of the speculator market so long
story short is a lot of creators
ended up scattering and doing what
they're doing now which is um
crowdfunding a lot of their comic strips
so you get a lot of the
creators who want to i don't know
i create an indiegogo or something like
that and i say hey everyone who follows
me if you want to buy this book you can
back the book
but what happens in japan there's there
was a famous story a couple of weeks ago
or a couple of days ago
where one manga series called demon
slayer i think is outselling the entire
american comics industry wow just one
well hold on hold on
manga that was the second question as
animators what do you think of the demon
slayer movie
okay i never saw it yeah but the the
story is interesting because all right
real real quick demon slayer in america
is outselling entire american comics
i'm not sure in america but maybe
worldwide like if you go to barnes noble
right now right
if you look at the comics section the
graphic novel section the western comics
versus the manga section
the manga section is almost always three
times the size
for various reasons but people here even
want to read more manga like young
people want to read manga more than
american comics they're more
into it for numerous reasons i've always
said like
manga is like the mma versus if you've
ever seen those uh videos of the mma
fighter versus like the
tai chi fighter and it's just like a
brutal beatdown of like
american comics look really great but if
you pit american comics versus manga
manga is going to win
every time why is that there's i could
do a whole feast
i'll tell you this when i see these like
ultra woke trash comics yeah
no one wants anywhere near that nobody
wants why did that happen it seems like
that happened to comics in a way that it
just hasn't happened to other people in
an overt way so most creative industries
lean to the left
but it just seems like comics are really
far to the left compared to the other
ones and in a much more overt way
movies and television shows will have a
left-wing message
but they're not like making a big deal
of the fact that they are having a
left-wing message not as often
yeah but but that's but why comics
why don't the same rules apply to these
others probably because there's about
disney bought more
hold on my my assumption is that comic
sales were slumping
and these companies thought we're only
getting white men
we have this whole untapped audience of
diversity of like you know non-white
female et cetera so how could yes that's
what a lot of them do they think
their core audience is this one group
and how do we expand into all these
other areas
so what they start doing is making
diverse
messages because they think that's what
people want instead of realizing
nobody wants that and maybe you should
just make
so so i'll put it this way it used to be
that if you were a
tv host you're you're super rich now
there's
millions of hosts who do youtube shows
who are all doing well
who are well off but not like 50 million
dollars like you know hannity is
it's changing so these comics start
seeing their sales decline instead of
saying
let's make another brand new comic for
this market they say
let's make iron man a young black woman
because then
the iron man fans will watch and read
and the
other communities who don't now will and
it's like no no now you've just made a a
weird character that nobody cares about
yeah
it doesn't work that way i look at i
look at manga
it's not in there like i got i got
crunchyroll man and i'm like
each and every one of these action shows
i just watch i'm like wow that's
actually pretty good
i've never watched any anime um but
i'm curious i mean it could also just be
that the stories are more interesting to
people yeah what's your thesis
george at least man all right so i i
don't know if you guys know but like
there was a company called tokyo pop
back in the
mid 2000s that was translating a lot of
manga
back before the uh recession of 2007-8
there was
a long story short they were trying to
do original english manga and i was
involved with that stuff i had my first
book was published through them
but what was happening with manga in
those years and even in the late 90s was
a lot of manga was getting published
in english uh that's why they started
doing the whole
um if you the formats going from right
to left because in the original
japanese they read from right to left so
a lot of it seemed foreign and weird at
first but
they weren't flipping the books anymore
you had companies like viz
uh tokyo pop uh
anyway there were a lot of companies
doing this but you want to talk about
diversity for example like there were so
many
female creators in japan creating uh
let's say
shoujo series that's a girl series you
know
i've got a couple of uh rumiko takahashi
uh masami suda fuyumi rumiko yasha and
dude she did so many and if you want to
talk about like female creators
those are manga massive she's one of the
richest uh manga creators in history
woman and there was no i there was no
inkling of like oh she was oppressed or
she wasn't she just made good books and
she found an audience
that wanted to buy and read her stuff
they were crazy about it even here in
the states that's why if i go to barnes
noble
i try to like talk to some people like
hey why do you read this series
and they just tell me oh i just like the
story i want to find out what's
happening
next even though it's not in color
americans love books and color but
if you give them like berserk the
creator of berserk kentaro miura
recently died
everybody now was talking about all of
last week we're talking about how much
they love berserk
it's a black and white series one of the
coolest darkest fantasy series you've
ever heard of
they love that series is it by romiko uh
berserk yeah no that's kentura major uh
yeah
i was going to say though uh uh for in
inuyasha what year was that 90s
uh 80s i want to say the manga at least
the
anime would have been 90s so so inuyasha
is about a furry
and ranma is about a transgender martial
artist really
but there's a reason i don't watch anime
but people were reading those i'm
grossly mischaracterizing the enemies no
but in a way i mean
really that gives you an idea of the
people just wanted to read a story that
they wanted to enjoy there was no
pushing of an ideology yeah for them
especially manga story is the king
you've got
the writer all right so you've got the
mangaka
who is the writer artist who has
assistance working with them and then
you've got the editor who helps them
write the stories
but they're really focused on what's how
how do i get the readers to read the
next chapter always
they're planning the story in such a way
like i just started getting onto one
piece and i can't get enough of it
it's so fun and i want to find out
what's happening next and i just like
the characters i like the world it's fun
to read
an american comic nowadays like i open
it and i have to push myself
i have to force myself to turn the page
it's so boring
and i can't explain why but when i read
a manga i can't put them down yeah
it's it's crazy but it's a martial arts
thing to me like i just i grew up
reading manga
my whole life i i i grew up hanging out
at comic shops
and they've just always been boring to
me have you
but if you saw a manga on the shelf like
did you feel
yeah dude full metal alchemist you gotta
know what happens next
the politics of it was brilliant yeah i
loved the
92 91 is when i got into comics i was
reading like the infinity gauntlet
x-force was all right x-men they were
good stories i mean the relationship
between gene gray and like
jubilee for like cyclops and like you
know colossus or whatever
and then and spawn came out and it was
like oh this is amazing this is jim
lee's
started a new company with image and
then maybe they just fell into the
spectacle i mean mar
marvel got bought that industry got
torched by disney basically it looks
like
marvel was struggling for a long time if
you look at the history of what happened
with image those all right tom mcfarlane
uh rob liefeld and all those guys they
were originally
they were the top guys at marvel and
they all decided to quit at the same
time
and form image comics there was this
whole flip of like the whole industry
turned upside down
and everyone was like oh all right so a
few years later there was something
called the speculator market which
a lot of comic books were selling
like a superman number one sold for a
ton of money and everyone's like oh i
gotta buy
issue one of this book and there's all
these variant covers
it's super rare so i have to invest in
this comic so what ended up happening
unfortunately was
image comics was so successful that they
were selling millions and millions of
copies of their first issues
everyone was buying them and it created
a bubble by accident and then the bubble
popped
so all these comic shops like novelty
comic shops that used to be card shops
opened and then closed and everyone saw
the recession it's like oh
comics are over but it was just a bubble
so
image comics is an interesting anomaly
and then all right so they were
struggling for a while and then
uh image comics did all right they had
walking dead which was really really
successful
robert kirkman ended up becoming a
partner at image after
uh walking dead was doing really good um
which is another black and white book
incidentally and everybody wanted to
it was one of those page turner books
that everyone wants to find out what
happens next
just go back to the 80s man and it was
just
a lot of really great stuff yeah and
then i don't know what happened like
90s 2000s ebay destroyed the market
what i mean is the writing so so we're
talking about like manga and anime
versus comics right
so i'm i'm growing up and i'm reading
comics
in like 2000 and they're getting dry and
boring and i'm reading and i'm just like
you know what it might be i can only
read about cyclops so many times yeah
sure
but you know with i started watching
dragon ball z
i watched that in the 90s i was a little
kid it was on it was it was
i turned on channel 50 at 8 in the
morning it was like or i think the only
way to watch it was in spanish
and so there's like that scene where
vegeta that's why you speak vegeta
vegeta is about to kill napa
and napa goes and then vegeta blasts
them
and i'm like vodka and then uh but but
then
you know i'm a little kid and i started
watching and i'm like whoa and like the
lore was really cool because i'd watch
an episode
and then someone would start telling me
like here's this character here's what
here's
here's what happened 10 years ago i'm
like whoa and i'm getting really really
into it
i opened a comic yeah like a lot of the
x-men lore and like the dc lore stuff
was interesting
but it started to get boring and then
the difference is
there's so much different manga that are
that are long that are in depth that
have different characters
that i could just find the one that i
thought was really good and stick to it
and watch it or read it and get to the
whole thing
i don't know man you you compare like
the full metal alchemist the politics of
that manga
brilliant like government corruption and
just the general
aspect of how they have the powers they
have alchemy they can just make things
with code like they write on the tables
or whatever
and then you have death note which is
probably one of the greatest fantastic
yeah just brilliant yeah and that's like
what can we say
right now mcu cool i like the mcu movies
but it's regurgitated
they're not hiring or searching for new
talent like the way that manga
they all right shonen jump and all those
uh companies over there they have talent
searches
all the time submit your stuff submit a
chapter the editors will pick the best
you get to talk to an editor maybe you
get to develop a series over here in the
states
all right so you got even veteran
creators i was talking to a veteran
creator who
has multiple eisner awards super amazing
he used to
almost say his name out of respect i
guess but like he can't find work
anymore because the editors running
marvel dc they won't even talk to him
because they're woke
they're woke and he let's say is
conservative let's say there's a whole
bunch of
i won't name names but there's a whole
bunch of conservative creators who can't
find
work in the industry but they're able to
get crowdfunding there are some of them
who
have hundreds of thousands of dollars a
couple of them broke even millions on
their books
what should is there like an american
shonen jump
no should there i mean there is a
translated version
of shonen jump right i mean like our
version of there needs to be an
anthology yes
the problem is with printing i don't
know if i mentioned last time i print my
own books at home let's say
i can't do a lot like i'm not like i'm
i'm doing all this stuff by myself but
like
to print and color is so expensive you
would have to print tens of thousands of
books just to break even let's say
yeah but you ship but doesn't doesn't
show and do the manga chapters and they
do it in black and white but they can
yeah
they have it's called an anthology if
you've ever seen heavy metal in america
um but yeah if you look at shonen jump
uh pulp used to do it back in the 90s
too
there needs to be things like talent
searches anthologies creators
creators nowadays like we're trying to
do
indie comics it's just that to get
funded to do them
is so hard and those of us who get
funded we're working super slow because
like i have a book called mary sue for
instance that just got it got funded
like
months ago and i'm trying to find time
to work on it
it just barely got funding right on
right i was just thinking an awesome
new genre would be have you ever seen
the app where you you take a beer bottle
and you
you scan it with the app and it animates
the picture on the beer bottle becomes
an animation
if you had a comic like that you opened
you read the comic or you could put your
phone up and
view it and it's a cartoon happens it's
cool i mean
you could just go on the website and
watch the cartoon you know the argument
of digitizing comics like they've
they've been trying to experiment with
that for a long time and then there's
the people who want to have a physical
book
at the store or mailed to them we should
we should move on but i just want to
point out
that this is this is a really good
example of american cultural stagnation
that you know it used to be that
americans were pushing culture and
culture was being exported
and now we have with comics i mean for
me growing up i'm not interested in the
amer
american conversation has crushed us
yeah it's over it's well good for them
uh i'll i'm part japanese i'll take
credit you guys you all suck nice work
moving on
the last part of the super chat because
that was a super chat was uh
uh sheamus jordan peterson doing a ben
shapiro impression
it's like okay if you're gonna tell me
that i can body the architectural mess
of the hair metaphorically dying and
you're also gonna argue for universal
health care absolutely out of your mind
because here's the thing we can't have
universal health care in a system where
people are actually being their best
selves because that requires that you
force other people to take
responsibility for your reactions all
right king oh my gosh
jordan peterson epic excellent
thank you garrett savant says white
skittles drain the rainbow
rob santana says tim the speaker at yale
found the line
do you think it will move and in which
direction of course it will move
over the line she didn't find the line
she's well past it too
she backflipped over it no it was like
it was like
a round off back layout it was it was it
was you know it was it was an excellent
maneuver
all right vapor trail says you can be
rich or you can be left-wing
everyone who is both is pure evil from
nico to silicon valley to hollywood
communism has always been an ideology of
the rich imposed from the top
down and they stay rich that is correct
karl marx was super rich wasn't he i
don't know he was born to a really
wealthy family i think
oh i i got i got a j max said with with
a big super chat
say the punch line gert damnit which one
well we're just going to move on from
that because i don't know what his
punchline was going to be and i don't
think we should get the show kicked off
youtube
no i'll have to tweet it josh van horn
says i released a children's book on
self-improvement that centers around
jealousy and loss it's called boy girl
monster
and it can be ordered from what does it
say umni rocks
oomni dot rocks it's my little part in
helping take the culture back thanks
crew that's cool
i pointed this out on my segment about
nico she's doing these tick tock videos
and she wears a bernie shirt
clearly she doesn't know a whole lot
about the ideology and it doesn't matter
young people who watch that will like
her and like bernie what am i doing what
are we doing here
well we're doing a vlog what do we have
in the skate park a big old gadsden flag
that's the point so people are going to
watch it i know what the gadsden flag
represents
don't tread on me it represents part
part of the american revolution a symbol
of it
and freedom liberty life liberty pursuit
of happiness and uh
when people watch the vlog and they see
something silly like you know chickens
eating cicadas or something
there it is building the culture having
those those symbols exist and be
and be prominent rainforest says i think
the skittle market
plan was we are getting rid of our
rainbow because only one rainbow matters
this month the rainbow flag
the store messed up yes that's that's
correct
uh that's what they did and it was
really really
dumb bad idea poorly executed
all right let's see what we got here in
the super chats
jack bailey says do you know about the
four basic personality types
sanguine chloric phlegmatic and
melancholy i highly recommend you look
them up
yeah explain shameless yeah so sanguine
choleric melancholic and phlegmatic
this is something that dates back to
ancient greece the idea is
you have people who are um
basically everyone fits into one of
these categories you're usually bleeding
into another category you'll have a
secondary
temperament but someone who is sanguine
is someone who is much more
in their body saying it actually means
blood it means
you're a person who takes more pleasure
in things laughs more often
and tends to be less responsible but
much more fun-loving
more pleasant and upbeat choleric people
tend to be more angry they're fiery they
like to analyze things they're a bit
more quick
phlegmatic people are the people who
more or less
don't care or seem not to care it takes
a lot to really get them
motivated about things they're very
chill as people
and then melancholic people are usually
very introspective they're more likely
to be down
about things and most people
fall into more than one cat it's rare
you meet someone who perfectly falls
into one of these categories
so you can take these tests i know i'm
like saying when cleric based on the
tests i've taken you guys are probably i
mean tim's definitely cleric i wonder
what your secondary is
um i highly recommend taking the test
it's very interesting i'm a sun and moon
pisces surprisingly
this is it's different it's different so
what's different about this
what's different about this and like
astrology is it's just an
interesting way of categorizing people
based on behaviors we know that they
have
made and the belief is that it's in the
body very much it's basically just like
it's it's yeah the the general idea is
there are certain aspects of your
personality that are just innate i think
that's
really what it's skating at there are
there's elements of you that aren't
necessarily
learned it's just who you are what what
what what animal are you
i'm the chinese i'm a human on the on
the chinese music oh i don't know i have
no idea
monkey are you someone you someone put
up on this one
i'm a tiger oh you're a tiger they
brought the temperaments up and it maybe
it was because earlier we were talking
about nature versus nurture and the fact
that you
really need to complete things i was
thinking of temperament when you were
talking about that as well i think
that's a huge part of it
we got a super chat here from nos he
says i've been having a really hard time
in my life
struggling with my life goals and other
things i know you guys say college is
bad but with what i want to do and the
way i learn
the best i need to been struggling with
school but this really helped inspire me
so thanks
glad to hear god bless you i'm glad we
could help definitely dude so what year
were you born in
79 did you look it up uh no no i'm i'm
in the process of it
every time i've heard his age before but
every time i hear it it still shocks me
42 the meaning of life
yeah oh according to what is it ian i
don't know where do i look for this
gorilla i'm looking at it i'm going to
just type in chinese zodiac
lydia's got it
every 12 years it repeats yeah
so you are would you say you were tim a
tiger yeah
that's fixed element wood it looks like
ian is a horse
sure does take a look at his face
[Laughter]
1992 95 95 yeah that's right i mean
1995. let's see
95 is a pig you're a pig about you bro
i'm a capitalist you know 25.
well i think that means you're a cat no
is it this just seems insulting frankly
are these stairs no he's an ox
you're an ox nice well i am it's like
none of these have started like ian
you're a sheep
we represent all the four elements we've
got water
fire earth i'm sorry you're an oxy earth
and tim you are
wood ian's a sheep oh i am yeah we need
to uh
so i'm not a horse yeah i don't know
okay sheep's not in here what are you
i don't know i didn't look at it are you
making fun of my political stance
one is also a sheep i don't see sheep
oh there are two sheep in this room
unbelievable you guys just aren't
independent thinking i'm not
walking it's true sheep aren't on my own
if you were born at a different time i'm
sorry
you'd be better at things you're all
much of sheep all right firefox says the
worst thing about the left is that they
look at an object and try to imagine
offensive stereotype associated with it
that being said we should stop talking
about harambe because it's racist and i
said so
that's sad to me harambe brian nord says
did you see the footage released to the
f-35
dropping a nuclear bomb in a test it
reminded me of what you were talking
about with escalating tension
did you guys know that the pentagon
stopped buying weapons for use in the
middle east and started buying weapons
for use in pacific warfare
yeah we were discussing military.com
reported this and i'm like bro people
you gotta like
you look at the grains of sand in the
news stories it's like
uh the pentagon is avoiding is is
pulling back on war with isis and
escalating war with china
and then like china says we're going to
go we're going to start preparing for
nuclear
war with america yeah then taiwan says
china's preparing for war
and like they're crossing the taiwan
straight the center line which is crazy
wasn't that the reaction to to our
discussion of investigating the origins
of the virus
which is what you do when you're
innocent did you hear what joe biden
said
probably the scariest thing come on man
i was like whoa
oh no come on man you got hairy legs
she went down she should think he's like
he's like if i could beat corn
pop i can beat you dude that's that's
what i found very large
china's isn't that kind of a telling
response we're like we're going to
investigate this actually if you do i'll
kill you
maybe you're guilty mr toad says can we
get a g prime 85 and freedom tunes
production of a fungus butt cartoon
oh my gosh we were talking about this
yeah we were talking about this
virus that right this fungus yeah which
is ruining cicadas by
causing fungus to grow out their fungus
and
basically we got into
the implications of a virus like that
crossing over to human beings and how
horrifying it would be
like like the last of us uh yeah the
last of us but like instead of their
heads
it produces this fungus makes them
produce like amphetamine and then they
go hypersexual crazy their nature
falls off they they protect themselves
that's right
yeah they pretend to be female so the
males will bang them and then spread the
fungus and they spread the fungus
seems like a job just for me it does
doesn't it frankly i heard this and i'm
like yeah
i'm the man for that full book that's
right the whole book fungus spot
and their bunkus on their mom fungus
1976 says if you get a hundred thousand
likes
next friday will you guys dress up as
the 60s batman cast and have a chef
prepare you various bugs and critique
the food on cass castle
if we get a hundred thousand likes on a
single episode we will dress up like the
cast of the 1960s batman as we do the
show and we won't mention it once
just can't even say anything i'm into it
just hold on i didn't i'm just saying i
didn't agree to this so maybe if i'm on
the show everyone else will be dressed
like batman characters will have to go
we'll have to get michael malus on the
show yeah malice would do it yeah
what what would he dress up as though
and know him
he's a riddler yeah he's a riddler
here's a serious one bretton maybe says
the tiananmen square massacre was 32
years ago today
wow please remind your audience to never
forget absolutely it's a big deal
you know they got that footage out did
you hear about it no oh we forgot to
talk about this sorry oh no
what and what darn it did you see the
gofundme matt walsh shut up to help
aoc's abuela this morning
it's up to 93 000 as i write this i
wonder what nasty poorly thought out
thing she will say about those who
donated
i wanted to launch the get aoc's abuela
a tesla gofundme
so she can ride in style to her new crib
so what happened
she lost her house it's just dilapidated
i see it so now we're gonna crowdfund
her out of it but let's let's support
this i think this is
good it is obviously a good turn for our
political uh turmoil
it's the most epic own ever we totally
helped your grandma
like high-five each other but no that is
the thing
all right i i love that um
i love that for as difficult as things
are getting and is as horrible
as uh as as tensions are
like we're still going to leave the
grandmas out of it you know i'm not
gonna say
we're clearly involving her but like
they're being cooled to grandma dude i'm
imagining
like science at the daily wire hq like
ben shapiro and and you know like
matt walsh they high five each other and
they're laughing like we don't have
owned afc oh my goodness guys okay and
she's never gonna recover from this
folks your house
your grandmother's house is repaired get
owned all right libs that's right
it's weird like what's good aoc is gonna
be like thank you very much
like i i'm curious this is it's a really
really smart move because
aoc i think will want to react
tribalistically because people are just
in tribes
but the appropriate response is like
thank you i saw people responding to uh
matt's tweet about it they're like
you're sick
[Laughter]
he raised a hundred grand friends with
grandma he is legally obligated to give
it to her
it's not a scam he's actually doing it i
guess
it's like you know i read that tipping
in asia is is
isn't is an insult like you know if you
go around because it's like you
you think i'm a charity case you're
telling the owner that they can't they
can't afford to pay their staff their
staff need
help well the staff already works so
hard that they feel like
i've already given it my all there's
nothing more that you can give me to
reward me
it's changing nowadays but like i guess
that's the idea like ben shapiro tweeted
he put in 500
the standard monthly payment for the
tesla to help
aoc's abuela and it's like clearly being
disrespectful
but giving her grandma 100 grams of
money it's kind of a
weird thing yeah it's like but
part of why i guess it's an own is
because we're showing that these
problems can be solved
through voluntary charity it's not just
about the government and it's hilarious
because people on the left will totally
miss that point when it comes to
gofundme and other crowdsourcing
platforms
every single time someone does something
charitable they're like that's just
socialism
they're like can you believe these
conservatives trying to raise money for
their cause it's like dude
hey we're not talking about seizing the
means of production here but b even if
you want to argue that the government
doing anything is socialism just helping
people
isn't socialism you can do that
privately that's been our entire
argument yeah
yeah scott brumley says jesus did not
speak out against the empire
he talked about personal responsibility
and devotion to god he never spoke about
things of this world like governments
even when he went before
pilate he didn't say anything about rome
uh he did speak of governments but
it's it's true i mean he did speak of
governments because he talks about
rendering unto caesar but
it's true i mean a lot of people will
try to uh take jesus and just fit him
into their particular political ideology
or they'll say things like jesus as a
socialist and
which is completely ridiculous i mean if
you're so brainwashed that you think
this ideology that came around in the
1800s was being embodied by christ
uh 2000 years ago you're um i mean
you're at a point we almost can't be
reasoned with because
basically what happened was marxism
plagiarized certain good elements of
christianity
uh and then bastardized them and then
did away with a lot of the parts of
christianity that are actually
worthwhile and became openly hostile
towards them
but then because they stole some values
from christianity they start saying see
christianity is marxist or jesus was
marxist it's like no you're getting it
backwards you took some of our
principles and now you're sort of
projecting that onto us
and arguing that we took them from you
but we were here first
yeah ian when you mentioned that about
jesus being against the empire they
actually expected jesus to come with a
sword
and to actually take back the kingdom
for the people who follow god and that
he told them this is not the case this
is not what i'm doing my kingdom is not
of this world and also he's referring to
a kingdom as well here yeah um so
yeah it's not a problem with an innate
problem with a political structure
all right general xta says i'm an
electrician and the economy is wrecking
everything
the price of material is exponentially
going up because the combination of
inflation and shortage of raw material
even bidding is lasting less than a
month
crazy man drew richmond says tim to
explain some of the recent shortages you
should watch the wendover productions
video about 2021 shortages
it would answer a lot of your questions
about what's causing a lot of the supply
shortages right now
my question is you know where do we go
from here and so i mentioned this
yesterday i'll say it again today
because you know george didn't hear it
the work that we got done on the studio
to expand i would not be able to do this
time because it's four to five times
it's more expensive
yeah so that means the money that we
made last year has lost eighty or
somebody
value in terms of expanding this
business isn't that insane
and the investments we made last year
are worth five times what we put into it
that's crazy yeah i bought i bought a
stack of bitcoin
like six years ago and forgot about it
and now i'm just looking at it like
man i'm excited about shipping container
housing as a future i got contacted by
someone that runs a shipping container
company live in the pod ian live in the
pods on the bus
eat the bugs baby we we didn't we did
the buck we had cricket bread last uh
living
dream molded fast yeah like a day
because it's meat oh there was an egg in
it too i think we did an egg in it too
baby animal product tends to mold faster
than um
plant products crickets yeah yeah
all right let's see we gotta be in the
old uh old
super chits sam t says all colors in the
visual light spectrum combine to make
white light
maybe that was skittle's point science
illiterate people don't get it
that's what i'm saying nerdy joke
xrunner says the second rpg video game
for south park you can play as
black less loot less xp and trade in at
shops saying the title can get you
banned uh it's actually funny that the
difficulty you can it's a difficulty bar
like you can make it more difficult and
if you choose hard mode your character
turns black
it's a really funny joke that is very
funny gareth green says koalas are not
bears they are marsupials
also apparently elderly japanese people
commit crimes to get in jail so they'll
so they will be taken care of
oh my goodness wow crazy man that's
really sad
that's great indicative of a problem i
would say so
and the way the system is built
uh brynn terranova says first time long
time re-comics
george how do you feel about the
storytelling in web comics and
specifically publishers like hive works
hive works i haven't heard of but um
let's see web comics have been a thing
for a very long time i would say since i
was in high school at least
uh you got the grandfathers like pvp
penny arcade those guys
and they were able to monetize for a
very long time
um i guess since a lot of the audiences
have shifted over to social media
so i publish my stuff mostly on
instagram and twitter and stuff like
that
i don't really have a website that i
fully like i don't maintain and i'm not
very responsible with it but i've been
doing all right
webcomics you see it really depends on
the reader preference do i want to read
a book on a screen
or on a piece of paper a book do i want
something i can collect
and give to my friends there's something
shareable about that
um it's kind of a kitchen sink problem
like for instance show it and jump i
think you can subscribe for like two
bucks a month or something like that
and you can read their entire history
from like decades back you can read it
for free
and that was a response to people
reading scanlations for the longest time
i used to do that i used to download
anime like on my
56k modem back in the day like every
every wednesday when the scandalation
for naruto would come out yeah
from the beginning to the end for like
how long was it like 15 years or
something longest time yeah i did that
yeah but i mean the response to that i
remember i went to
i was lucky enough to go to japan and i
talked to a couple of editors
uh the editor that was working on naruto
actually
he told me that their biggest problem at
the time this was 2014
was dealing with pirating uh here in the
states
they know they knew that the passion for
manga was huge
here in the states but people didn't
have the money like the audience
say teenagers 20 somethings they want to
read the books but they don't have a ton
of money to like if you want to read one
piece now there's 97 volumes or
something
that's nuts even at 10 bucks each back
in the day or 12 bucks now you can't
afford that yeah and
you don't have the shelf space for it
anyway so webcomics
solved that problem and that you could
read the entire
catalog i don't i wouldn't know how to
monetize that personally like there's a
couple of solutions
that i would propose for creators like
say i have a patreon i can put my entire
catalog
on patreon right now you can read my
whole catalog that's one way to solve it
or
i offer my comic strips for free on
twitter and
i have like a tip jar system it's not
perfect but i think
there's a sort of relationship that can
be developed
cultivated between creators and audience
having a middleman like a publisher can
help but then you have to ask what
what value does the publisher bring what
value does the
retailer bring if you don't have money
money
right like right now uh the biggest
problem the past couple of years is that
there was a distributor called diamond
distribution in the states that uh
long story short if i had a book that i
wanted to sell at comic book shops i
would have to sell
or solicit a couple thousand of them
say 3 000 and they wouldn't even touch
my property if i couldn't sell 3 000.
i would have to ship print my books send
them to diamond and they would
distribute them to retailers who would
order my book
based solely on the title that they
would find in a catalog that makes sense
it was a terrible system especially for
indie creators
right so indie creators in the states
have a really hard time right now
finding um finding an audience and
finding like
to even talk to a publisher they won't
talk to you but most of the time unless
there's a lot of maybe i'm biased but i
think there's a lot of nepotism going on
in the uh i won't name names but like
there are
there are certain publishers unless
you're friendly with them already like
you can go and talk to them
at a convention uh talk to an editor or
i know a guy who knows a guy
who will get me a book deal so i can
write um
and we'll find an artist who lives in
like thailand or something who will work
for like pennies
um but their their quality ironically
their quality is just as good if not
better than a lot of american creators
and they cost nothing almost well we got
the super chat from
rockslide he says i'm an anti-woke
artist and plan to make lots of cool
comics
elevator pitch a futuristic world where
mythology is real and that's just one
i want to build culture like you've said
i would absolutely fund a
manga or graphic novel or like manga
we're not japanese
like a production company what should
happen and i think it can happen there
just has to be like a sort of uh
pirate attitude not pirate but like all
right say
i have a certain number of people on
twitter that follow me and like
read my stuff or something like that i
know how to print books
i know how to write books i know how to
draw i can do the entire production
myself
so if i were to get a couple of people
that i
that know how to also do this a couple
of editors a couple of
people who can oversee certain steps on
the production line we can print a
couple thousand
copies of an anthology let's say get a
couple of creators who will
do a 20-page short story you guys submit
your book
submit your story uh if your story does
well maybe we'll do another volume after
this so
you can crowdfund something like this
like i could just say
anthology we'll call it whatever the
what was the
butt cicada fungus
you call this anthology bungas fungus or
something volume one
and you just get like a couple dozen
creators who submit a 10
20 page story in color black and white
whatever it's just a single volume thing
all right let's do it you can crowdfund
that pretty quick crowdfund it let's
just do it i'll fund it
well all right we could talk about this
afterwards but like for instance so
everybody you heard it if you got
if you if you've drawn up a graphic
novel and you've got a series and
we're going to do an anthology even just
a short story i think that's the right
way to go just introduce yourself as a
creator
and we'll have like a submission system
you can do something like that boom
i mean really it's not that hard and
it's kind of a talent search kind of
thing so that you can gain an audience
everybody shares
all right say i have 70 000 people
whatever on twitter not a couple
uh 40 000 whatever on instagram
i can share that audience uh and then
some other creator comes along and
brings their audience and they are
introduced to mine mine is introduced to
theirs we share
the audience we can get comics going
again it's sort of like a jump start
kind of thing but
let's do it all right so that's the
biggest obstacle i think for american
creators
who want uh an in and some veteran
creators can contribute to something
like this just
just start doing it everybody submit
your uh your
your graphic novels your comments your
short stories to our pages at
timcast.com and we'll start uh
publishing and what we'll figure out
we'll make we'll make a portion of the
website we'll do we'll we'll find a
handful of series that we think are good
and then we'll we'll we'll aim for like
a chapter a week right
chapter a week would be very high all
right so in japan they do a chapter a
week like 18 pages but they
yes have a ton of assistance helping
them uh that was the big problem with
bleach though the guy was overwhelmed he
got so burnt out
same thing with berserk and uh i love a
series called
uh vagabond where the same thing
happened where they have assistance but
they get burnt out
uh in america it's so a chapter a day
america it's like 20 something pages per
month something like that i think is
reasonable for a single creator
yeah that's that's that's rough that's
pretty slow yeah manga comes out faster
it's in black and white that's the
problem yeah we'll do in black and white
all right
well we could talk about the software
again well i'm doing it anyway so
pictures at tempest.com that's happening
all right we'll have i'm totally down
have a section for our comics
uh anyway it's uh we're getting late so
everybody go to go follow us
at tim cast irl on facebook and
instagram help share our videos you can
follow me at tim casts friday night we
got the vlog coming out tomorrow where
we eat the bugs and
you'll probably enjoy it it's fun
another weird shenanigans and uh
it's gonna be a good time so thanks for
hanging out man it's been a blast
uh subscribe to this channel hit the
like button share with your friends
become a member leave us a good review
uh george you want to shout anything out
uh yeah just if you guys want to follow
me i'm g prime85 on twitter and
uh instagram and if you want to buy my
stuff i have my links
to my shop in my bio on both and i'm on
patreon too if you just want to throw me
a tip
and uh try to offer my stuff for free as
much as i can and
buy my books buy other indie creators
books and let's see what happens with
this uh
anthology thing right that's a great
idea uh follow me at sourpatchlids on
twitter
that's great i i'm at youtube.com
freedomtunes that's where i post my
cartoons we do uh
we do two a week we only were able to do
one because we were trying to get caught
up but we do two cartoons a week you
guys should really enjoy them
and uh also if you want to support the
show i guess patreon.com
freedom tunes or if you want to buy one
of our shirts freedomtunesmirch.com
there we go
uh and i do want to remind you fungus
fungus and fungus
if you want to help your enemies
grandmother go ahead shout out maybe
we've got more in common than we thought
if you were an artist draft the story of
the bungas fungus
the fungus from the bungas and it's
about a fungus that
makes people's butts fall off and
replaces their butt with a fungus and
turns them into
bungas zombies like i could see an
entire industry
creating new underwear just for those
people so it's kind of like a pair
it's it's a parody of uh the last of us
it really is
the strawberries but it's bunga's fungus
no but it's like
a guy it's a guy he's reading buzzfeed
and buzzfeed says eat a cicada and he's
a soy boy and he does
and then he gets the bungas fungus and
then he becomes the first patient zero
of the
bunker fungus zombie apocalypse tim when
the bunnies write it up submit it
we will publish that's when the longest
fungus zombie apocalypse actually
happens you're gonna be very embarrassed
i know that right now there's like 10
people like running and like drawing the
first chapter
draw it with your butt if you can yes no
i'm serious
let's get the fungus from the bungus
zombie apocalypse comic
yeah and i'm in the corner pushing
buttons i am sarah patchlids on twitter
you guys can follow me there i am trying
to get more followers than sour patch
kids who i was happy to note
did not change to a rainbow symbol on
twitter
this month i like that that is pretty
good thanks for hanging out everybody we
will see you tomorrow at youtube.com
cast castle and you can watch us hang
out eat the bugs
and we'll see you then bye guys
you